si on est d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
les news ne s'arrête jamais mais c'est
votre soutien que nous apprécions le
plus
[Musique]
on
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau et nos
reporters sur le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi 14 janvier emmanuel macron
promet de continuer à expliquer et
concertée sur le projet de la réforme
des retraites
des propos qui interviennent alors
qu'une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
s'est déroulée aujourd'hui à paris mais
aussi à lille
certains syndicalistes se sont retrouvés
à ivry sur seine pour le blocage du
centre de déchets de la ville
des heurts ont éclaté avec les forces de
l'ordre
la conférence internationale sur la
libye aura lieu ce dimanche à berlin
hier la réunion organisée par la russie
avec les deux rivaux libyen a permis des
progrès selon moscou alors que
diplomatiquement les efforts se
multiplient pour trouver une issue
rapide
le parlement turc erdogan promet
d'infliger une leçon à rallye farce
il reprend ses attaques paris londres et
berlin déclenché une procédure visant à
contraindre téhéran à se plier à ses
engagements nucléaires conclut dans
l'accord de vienne de 2015
dans la foulée lire en les mettant en
garde contre les conséquences d'une
telle décision qui selon moscou pourrait
conduire à une nouvelle escalade
là des propositions pour améliorer la
déontologie des policiers et des
gendarmes
c'est la demande formulée par emmanuel
macron alors que la police fait face à
plusieurs accusations de viol rompt
score des dernières manifestations ou
dans la sphère cédric joue via le
président qui a rappelé que les forces
de sécurité intérieures sont aussi les
premières victimes
[Musique]
c'est le premier revenante g10 france
libéré de prison s'était hier après 7 en
vain car ces rations alors qu'une grosse
trentaine de libération sont attendus
cette année
quel suivi pour ces détenus condamnés
pour terrorisme sont ils des ex
prisonniers comme les autres ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
alors qu'il est à pau aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron s'est exprimé sur le
sujet central des retraites le chef de
l'état assuré que le gouvernement
continuerait à s'expliquer et concertée
pour lever les inquiétudes qu'ils
estiment légitime
il a également répété son engagement à
mettre fin aux régimes spéciaux malgré
le mécontentement de ceux qui les
protègent
il faut donc reconstruire un monde où
les droits sont attachés à la personne
le système beaucoup plus simple pour
chacun donc ces inquiétudes devraient
être progressivement lever elles sont
levés par les clarifications technique
par les discussions et négociations et
sur le fameux sujet du financement par
la concertation qui commence depuis
quelques jours et qui va se faire à
travers la conférence de financement
donc il faut avec beaucoup de calme
maintenant de clarté que notre pays
rentre dans cet état d'esprit
voyez quand on quand on prend la peine
d'expliquer calmement et d'écouté on
peut lever beaucoup d'ambiguïtés de
malentendu on ne lèvera pas le
mécontentement
évidemment de gens qui protège des
catégories particulières qui ne sont
plus soutenables dans la durée et
auxquels je me suis engagé à mettre fin
et qu'elle le gouvernement mettra fin
est pour le chef a de la france
insoumise jean luc mélenchon la gauche
doit voter motion censure contre le
gouvernement a coûté nous allons
proposer au groupe communistes et
socialistes de déposer une motion de
censure contre ce gouvernement
quel est le sens de voter sur un texte à
trous qui n'est pas complet le
gouvernement doit être mis au pied de
ses responsabilités sous la réforme des
retraites est toujours les mêmes
revendications le retrait total de la
réforme les syndicats les plus
déterminés ne décolère pas et sont
appelées à trois journée une
manifestation non celle d'aujourd'hui à
paris qui a réuni plusieurs milliers de
personnes
rassemblement à l'appel de la fsu
solidaires jeunes
cgt et fo les précisions de lille a fait
à mons où le cortège est parti peu après
14h du métro école militaire direction
la rue du bac dans le 7e arrondissement
parmi les manifestants aussi bien des
organisations syndicales que des
étudiants ou encore des gilet jaune et
malgré l annonce du gouvernement de
retirer l'âge pivot tous restent
déterminés et ne réclame qu'une seule
chose le retrait pur et simple de la
réforme des retraites je propose de les
écouter
la réforme est venu au bon point pour
remobiliser les gens au final parce que
les gens se rendent compte comment ça se
passe vraiment dans les manifestations
et le peu de réponses que nous apporte
quand on manifeste pour quelque chose
sur laquelle on n'est pas d'accord et
chaque sortie d' emmanuel macron ou de
son premier ministre
elles sont très bien aussi pour
mobiliser les gens viennent tous parce
que du tout même les grévistes qui
avaient pas encore participé au logis
les jaunes et qui avait l'habitude de
manifester avant se rendre compte de
tout ce qui est en train de passer ya là
il ya beaucoup de réformes il ya la
sécurité sociale qui va arriver il ya la
pl il ya le chômage
là on essaie sont celles des retraites
mais on a plein d'autres qui arrivent en
fait c'est une course contre la montre
ce gouvernement veut passer le maximum
de réformes et a pu avoir besoin de
revenir là dessus
donc c'est très dangereux à la fin de
son quinquennat et leurs limites fait le
travail leur a même pas besoin de se
représenter à la motivation elle est
entière ça c'est sur balles à toute
façon quand on voit la régression nos
acquis sociaux a peut être que entière
qui on va pas se faire voler la vedette
du fait que tout le monde est sorti
aujourd'hui c'est bien parce que on a
été des crieurs d' alerte
il est temps que les gens prennent
conscience que ce qu'on défend était
juste et qu'on n'est pas si mauvais que
ça malgré tout ce qui a pu dire le
gouvernement dans sa communication pour
essayer de nous discréditer très peu de
tension à noter lors de cette
manifestation qui a duré un peu moins de
trois heures
elle les manifestants se sont retrouvés
1 rue du bac où ils se sont donné
rendez-vous pour jeudi pour la grande
journée de mobilisation nationale
six français sur dix soutiennent
toujours les manifestations et grève
contre les retraites selon le baromètre
harris interactive pour rtl et af info
un peu plus d'un tiers ressentent de
l'inquiétude élargissement des critères
de pénibilité une retraite garantie de
1000 euros sont massivement plébiscité
concernant le projet présenté 27% des
sondés souhaitent qu'il soit purement
annuler
et quand plus d'un sondé sur deux est
opposé à l'âge pivot de 64 ans écoutez
gouvernement les discussions se
poursuivent notamment avec les syndicats
enseignants
hier le ministère de l'éducation
nationale a promis 500 millions d'euros
de hausses de salaires pour les
enseignants dès janvier 2021
reste maintenant à savoir comment ces
revalorisations vont se traduire sur les
fiches de paie les échanges doivent
durer jusqu'à jeudi et pour nicolas
guiet enseignants et membres des stylos
rouges
cette somme ne permettra pas de
compenser le manque à gagner par la
réforme des retraites
nous avons réussi depuis un an à faire
entrer dans les têtes que nous étions
mal payé et ce n'est pas une vue de
l'esprit ce qu'une réalité
donc concrètement ce chiffre de 10
milliards
c'est ce que nous demandons depuis un an
les stylos rouges et les syndicats se
sont joints à nous pour demander cette
somme
le problème c'est qu'elle était demandée
sans compensation puisque cet argent
qu'on nous devait depuis 83 encore une
fois la bonne ou la lie à cette réforme
parce qu'on va avoir une énorme baisse
donc en fait ça ne ratera rien on
continue à avoir le point d'indicé est
gelé
l'inflation continue à grimper le
logement notamment en ile-de-france
atteint des prix terrifiant pour
n'importe quel salarié que ce soit la
location et encore plus à l'achat on ne
peut pas bien vivre de notre métier et
j'imagine pour d'autres métiers qui sont
vos plus grandes difficultés
je pense aussi aux aides-soignants aux
infirmières ces mêmes choses et les
blocages se multiplient un peu partout
en france c'est le cas devant
l'incinérateur d'ivry sur seine en
région parisienne actions menées par la
cgt un blocage auxquelles les forces de
l'ordre ont tenté de s'interposer ton ce
matin les grilles de l'entrée ont été
soudés f1 d'interdire l'accès à
l'incinérateur notre reporter david
khalifa était sur place
un chiffre à vous donner concernant le
traitement de déchets à paris trois
mille tonnes de déchets sont traités
chaque jour dans la capitale française
un peu plus de 2000 sont traités ici
même une
un blocage qui peut avoir donc de
lourdes conséquences sur l'accumulation
de déchets qui peut y avoir à paris cet
objectif est clair en tout cas pour
plusieurs de ces syndicats rester un
maximum de jours ici pour se faire
entendre du gouvernement et pour faire
retirer ce projet de loi de réforme de
retraite et cette contestation contre
cette réforme a malheureusement été le
théâtre de violences policières emmanuel
macron s'est exprimé sur le sujet le
président demande des propositions pour
améliorer et la déontologie des
policiers et des gendarmes
souhaitant que la justice puisse
continuer à travailler sur ces cas il
met en garde contre les amalgames
il insiste sur des violences dont je
cite les forces de sécurité intérieures
sont les premières victimes
et cette victime justement mortes à la
suite d'un contrôle de police une
information judiciaire a été ouverte
pour homicide involontaire famille et
avocat de cédric joue via parle d'une
bavure ils ont d'ailleurs été reçu
aujourd'hui par christophe castaner
cédric se souvient quarante deux ans est
décédé le 3 janvier dernier après son
interpellation par des policiers à paris
il a été victime d'une asphyxie avec une
fracture du larynx après avoir été
plaqué au sol casque sur la tête par
plusieurs agents de police écoutez la
réaction déçu de l'un de ses fils à la
sortie de cet entretien
il a répondu à certaines questions mais
bon on a quand même on est quand même
sorti en manque de quelque chose en
manque de au manque d'information parce
que voilà les policiers nous notre
principale question c était que qu'est
ce que font les quatre policiers qui ont
interpellé au mon père et il n'a pas été
en mesure de nous répondre
s'il ya s'il était toujours en le
service si il pouvait encore contrôler
les gens alors que airlines et que tant
qu'il n'aurait pas une information qui
dirait que l'interpellation et que
l'amendement père être provoquée par un
de leurs ges
il ne pourrait pas les suspendre alors
que voilà ça va faire presque deux
semaines que c'est dit clairement dans
tous les journaux dans tous les articles
que mon père a été tué par une fracture
du larynx
donc il ya fait qui a provoqué une
asphyxie
donc après si ça pour ce n'est pas une
preuve qui montrent que les policiers
ont
ont provoqué des actes envers mon père
déloyale et avec grande brutalité
je sais pas si on peut dire de plus et
c'est dans ce contexte qu'une autre
affaire de violences policières été
classée sans suite par le parquet de
paris la semaine dernière la gilet jaune
mélanie damien victime d'un coup de
matraque dans la nuque réagi au micro
d'rtl france un sujet de pâtes katia
pique nique le 8 avril 2019
légis les jeunes défilent à paris lors
d'une manifestation autorisée
mélanie une militante occupée à lire un
tract ne voit pas la charge de crs
derrière son dos elle est alors
violemment frappé par surprise par un
crs et elle s'effondre elle nous raconte
je suis seul où j'ai les bras levés j'ai
le papier dans la main un homme
fait 28 pas donc cours sur 30 mètres
arme son bras et massène un coup de
matraque dans la nuque
ces images signalé par le journaliste et
écrivain david dufresne provoque
l'indignation sur les réseaux sociaux
elles vont être visionnée plus d'un
million de fois mélanie travailleuse
sociale et porte-parole des gilets
jaunes d'avenir les réfractaires du 80
se souvient le père connaissance à
plusieurs reprises tiré trois à quatre
fois que je me souviens de la douleur et
je me souviens d'après la douleur j'ai
eu une entorse des cervicales et les
disques c4 et c5 qui sont morts la
légiste m'a dit que si jamais je n'avais
pas eu cette écharpe
je serai étape tétraplégique à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui pour moi c'était même pas
envisageable que ce soit un homme qui
ait fait ça délibèrement je ne pouvais
pas l'imaginer parce que moi j'ai grandi
dans une famille où nous a donné des
valeurs de respect qu'un uniforme ça se
respecte et cette mère de famille porte
plainte contre x
mais surprise début janvier le parquet
de paris classé la plainte sans suite
selon la justice le choix du policier
dollar poussée lors de sa charge était
justifiée même si la blessure subie
n'était pas recherché
il a en outre jugé que la vitesse de
marche de la gilet jaune
allez la laisser derrière le nouveau
barrage qu'ils essayaient d'établir ce
qui était dangereux
cette décision a révolté plusieurs
personnalités et bien entendu mélanie
dans mon éducation deux quartiers
populaires c'est ce qu'on m'a appris ce
que mon père m'a transmis
tu ne cours pas tu n'as rien fait
mélanie tu ne cours pas il ya que les
délinquants qui courent et que ceux qui
ont quelque chose à se reprocher qui
courent moi je cours je la mets sait
jamais rien à me reprocher en fait mais
il ya un recours on va aller jusqu'au
bout on va les saigner les recours tout
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire on le fera
mon but c'est pas de gagner de l'argent
c'est juste que quand une personne ne
tape le nom de mon agresseur dans google
y est pas toutes ses médailles parce
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
était même médaillé au mois de mai
mélanie affirme connaître l'identité du
crs en question le milieu militant crois
qu'il s'agit d'un homme déjà connu pour
des faits similaires il est important
que la police est une vraie police pour
les juger aujourd'hui en policier qui
lance un pavé qui ne touche personne
prend trois mois avec sursis comme
excuse
s'il fallait condamner quelqu'un c'était
une personne qui avait blessé un
manifestant un militant cette militante
n'est pas découragé de manifester et
continuer à fédérer les gilet jaune
d'amiens pour elle il est nécessaire de
ne pas plier devant la peur au nom du
combat pour la justice sociale et eux
aussi s'opposent à cette réforme des
retraites les employés de l'hôpital
public le collectif inter hôpitaux a
tenu plusieurs conférences de presse
l'occasion pour les médecins
hospitaliers de rendre publique la
lettre de démission collective de leurs
responsabilités administratives
la conférence de presse notamment la
pitié salpêtrière à paris les précisions
de notre reporter solène go d'action
démissionner de leurs fonctions
administratives c'est l'ultime recours
de ces mille médecins pour sauver
l'hôpital public à bout de souffle
je vous propose de les écouter on ne
remplace pas les départs à la retraite
ou de façon retardé on ne remplace pas
les congés de maternité ont créé des
superstructures pour mutualiser des
soignants ont changé leurs horaires on
n'augmente pas les salaires le salaire
aujourd'hui des infirmières en france
est au 28e rang des 32 pays de l' ocde
nous demandons donc une revalorisation
des salaires des soignants et la
réintroduction des services au centre de
la gouvernance de l'hôpital nous
démissionnons parce que nous voulons
sauver notre bien commun qui est
l'hôpital public
nous implorons notre ministre agnès
buzyn qui connaît l'hôpital
est ce qu'il y a travaillé comme nombre
dans des années de relever enfin la tête
et de résister aux injonctions de bercy
soit on essaye de sauver l'hôpital
public avec la vision qu'avaient robert
debré en 1958 et qui avait permis à la
médecine française d'être classée au
premier rang mondial par l' oms au début
des années 2000 soit on revient vers
l'hôpital hospice du xixème siècle qui
prend en charge les pauvres les démunis
les autres ayant recours à la médecine
privée
alors concrètement que signifie cette
démission administrative et bien les
médecins l'assurent ils continueront les
soins et l'accueil des patients en
revanche plus de gestion de planning
plus de formulaires plus de réunion et
une démission qui prend effet
immédiatement
un message politique fort envoyé au
gouvernement dans le but de créer un
électrochoc au ministère de la santé
pour relancer les négociations sur le
budget et les salaires alors qu'une
conférence internationale sur la libye
aura lieu dimanche le cessez le feu
reste en vigueur pour une durée
indéterminée informations des autorités
russes qui ont organisé une réunion avec
les deux rivaux libyen hier
sachez que chef du gouvernement ont
reconnu par l'onu fayez al zahra j'ai
officiellement signé cet accord de
cessez-le-feu
hanifa haftar lui a demandé plus de
temps pour y réfléchir les détails avec
grazailles à et florian lambert alors
qu'un accord de cessez le feu en libye
étaient en passe d'être signé khalifa
haftar a finalement quitté moscou ce
matin sans pas rater le moindre document
l'homme fort de l'est libyen avait
pourtant demandé un délai de réflexion
la veille son rival fayez al sara jade
est formellement adopté ce cessez le feu
entré en vigueur dimanche
aux manettes pour tenter de régler un
pompier en cours depuis 2011
moscou et ankara leurs ministres des
affaires étrangères respectivement
sergueï lavrov et mevlüt cavusoglu ont
affirmé l'importance de cet accord lors
de leur rencontre à mossoul
nous veillerons à ce que al sahar agf
par assument toutes les obligations
nécessaires que le cessez-le-feu se
poursuivent et que nous entamons le
processus politique se lèchent et ils se
poursuivent dans le cadre des efforts de
la communauté internationale
la partie russe travaillera avec dans
les mêmes temps turquie recep tayyip
erdogan rencontrait le président du
conseil des ministres guiseppe compter
tous deux ont insisté sur la nécessité
d'agir pour un accord durable e kenneth
meshoe lyonnais team il n'hésite seront
jamais a infligé aux petits star la
leçon qu'il mérite s'il poursuit ses
attaques contre l'administration
légitime et contre nos frères en
discussion qui souligne la science
croissante de la diplomatie conjointe
russo turques alors qu'une apparente
rivalité semblait se profiler sur le
terrain si fayez al chaar âge était
soutenu par ankara qui déploie ses
militaires en renfort en libye moscou
serait écoutée de khalifa haftar l'homme
de l'est du pays mais les deux partis
alliés dans la négociation ne renonce
pas sergueï lavrov a ainsi annoncé qu'il
poursuivrait ses efforts en vue d'une
trêve
ou si nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
dans ce domaine pour le moment le
résultat définitif n'a pas été atteint
une initiative soutenue par angela
merkel al'approche de la conférence
internationale sur la libye qui se
tiendra à berlin ce dimanche sous
l'égide des nations unies et pour en
parler nous sommes avec saad you more
est là quand tu es journaliste
spécialiste de l'afrique bonsoir stadium
henri leconte et merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france alors avant de
signer un accord formel dans le match à
la star aurait besoin de deux jours
supplémentaires pour l'étudier est-ce
qu'on peut il croire encore à cet accord
la cresse des biens de c'est tellement
embourbé et les différents protagonistes
qui veulent rentrer en lice actuellement
ne sont pas faits pour alléger
l'ambiance quand
avait pour allier les russes aujourd'hui
sa rage à pour rallier la turquie sur un
contre un sur un quartier de mer qui a
priori semble illégal et donc créer un
autre débat dans le débat déjà très
bouyer du conflit libyen mais alors
c'est haftar demandé quelques jours de
réflexion
j'espère que ça pourra lui permettre
d'intégrer les toubous dont on ne parle
pas dans ce conflit
j'espère aussi qu'ils vont intégrer
l'union africaine qui a pourtant une
commission qui devrait avoir son mot et
on voit que c'est plutôt un débat entre
occidentaux méditerranée et si à des
africains c'est sur la bande
méditerranéenne aussi jusqu'en egypte ça
s'arrête là justement vous nous dit on
n'en parle pas pourquoi est ce si
important d'intégrer ces partis il a
expliqué nous mais c'est sur le
continent africain
et vous voyez bien que depuis la
déflagration fils à l'agression de la
délégation de la libye comment le mal et
on souffre pas que tous ces pays au sud
du sahara sont tributaires des dégâts
collatéraux de la déliquescence de la
libye le terrorisme qui sont nourris et
on nous a mis en même temps comme
commission de l'ue de 2,1 du haut niveau
pour la gestion de la crise en libye
comme africains denis sassou nguesso qui
lui-même du congo brazzaville qui est
lui même un qui lui m'interresse son
peuple donc pourquoi il n'apparaît pas
dans ce dossier pourquoi l'afrique me ne
paraît pas dans la gestion de cette
crise là on aimerait bien avoir de plus
amples explications
est-ce que c'est dû à l'attitude part
qu'on qualifie de non-démocratique de
sassou qui emprisonne et là à noël et
vient de faire quatre prisonniers
supplémentaires
est ce qu'on ne veut pas en rajouter a
déjà ce qui est trés brouillées dans
cette gestion il ya autant de questions
que nous nous posons et nous aimerions
savoir pourquoi l'afrique mais pas n'est
pas présente en tout cas sage a accepté
de signer effectivement
mme aïcha la star n'hésite pas joue-t-il
selon vous comment vous vous l'expliquer
mais c'est je pense que le nouvel à la
turquie qu'est ce nouvel allié loeb est
un peu parce que va fragiliser cesser sa
marge de manoeuvre par rapport à la
turquie qui lui offre un pardon à la
russie qui même si c'est pas de façon
officielle il bénéficie quand même
désarmement russe via les mercenaires
donc voir que la rivalité
s'internationalise que des enjeux des
personnalités nouvelles on ajoute à ça
va le braquet et lui il va demander bien
sûr un temps de réflexion pour pouvoir
aussi peut-être avoir d'autres alliés et
pouvoir avoir une plus large marge de
manoeuvre afin de pouvoir partir en
position de force dans les négociations
et vous parliez de la turquie
effectivement récepteur de rien le
président turc s'est fait plus menaçant
prévenant qu'il n'hésiterait pas je cite
a infligé une leçon à l'homme fort de
l'est libyen s'est pas vraiment une
ambiance très diplomatique tout ça il
faut dire que dwan à 35000 à chuck sur
ce pays d'à et qu'il a investi des
milliers de milliards des millions de
milliards dans ce domaine là avant que
la libye ne chutent à ce point là bas
donc il y a une manne économique a
récupéré les entreprises turques qui
étaient là à récupérer et non seulement
aussi en plus il en riant il veut
compter il va avoir sa part dans ce
quartier de la méditerranée qui produit
du gaz et donc est très gourmand de la
turquie donc grands enjeux économiques
angers évidemment gso la ramener je sais
pas s'il existe de conflits de guerre
dans anges et économique
c'est comme on dit chez nous quand les
éléphants se battent c'est l'art qui
souffre dans son coeur au détriment des
populations les enjeux économiques sont
là et qui cause des effets ressentis
équipe temporise et enfin des déplacés
internes eu un entêtement aujourd'hui
depuis la chute de la libye dans chaque
pays du sahel il ya des déplacés
internes qui risque de s'accentuer si la
question libyenne n'est pas réglée et
comment le régler
j'aimerais aussi qu'on en parle alors
oui justement comment le régler
il ya une solution en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils espèrent à cette conférence
internationale sur la libye qui aura
lieu à berlin le 19 janvier
vous êtes optimiste vous y croyez à ce
règlement via cette conférence vous sous
l'égide de l'onu on le rappelle un
soulagés de ne générer que ce qui serait
bien ce qui sera important c'est de
fédéraliser déjà ce pays parce que d'un
côté quelqu'un qui est militairement
fort et d'autre part sa rage qui a tout
le soutien international avec les
nations unies et qui a un gouvernement
d'union nationale
ça fait un déséquilibre qui
déséquilibrent aussi d'autres tribus
comme tout bon qu'ils sont bien de là
bas et qui ne sont pas tenus en compte
est ce que si finalement on arrivait à
une fédéralisation et un gouvernement de
2,2 un gouvernement qui va chapeauter
sousse à sa vitre est pas imbibé
souveraine c'est ça une lubie laisser ce
soit a priori l'onu et c'est ce à quoi
devrait servir cette conférence voilà
donc on arriver à ça serait vraiment
l'idéal il faudrait donc que les uns et
les autres acceptent de se départir de
partir de leur souveraineté temps pour
sa rage que pour after pour que on y
arrive et les pays peut-être tourné le
dos alors justement leurs intérêts
économiques vous croyez que c'est
possible ça que le pays tourne enrico la
turquie oui voilà que les pays
effectivement qui sont très impliqués
dans ce conflit tourne le dos à leurs
propres intérêts peut-être et les
services sont réels
je pense que earth one va faire beaucoup
de chantage par rapport à la présence
militaire qui va mettre en disposition 2
de sarrazin qui sera qui pourra
équilibrer ses relations avec le
maréchal donc il va compter il pèsera et
peut-être qu'il arrivera à redessiner la
carte
la carte maritime dans cette partie de
la méditerranée là et ce sont nos
objectifs je crois que cela laissera pas
faire ou en lui cédera des parties dans
ce qu'il ne lui revient pas de droits ou
y mettrait du feu à la poudre on verra
ça merci oui de la journée qu'on fait de
l'huile sur le feu merci cet idiome
oreilles tentait d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france aux mairies dans
quelques instants nous recevrons notre
invité politique sébastien chenu porte
parole du rassemblement national député
du nord candidat également la mairie de
denain puis direction ensuite l'iran en
proie toujours à des manifestations
depuis lève des autorités sur le crash
du boeing
[Musique]
le handball est il géopolitique religion
il devrait l'être mais ne l'est pas pour
l'instant on voit pas des personnalités
capables de structurer à la fois du côté
business du côté comme et du côté
clairement géopolitique le hand qui soit
capable de rivaliser
non pas avec le foot mais avec les
sports qui sont juste à côté on constate
qu'il ya des rapports de force entre
états qui se manifeste au travers du
hand et on voit que dans l'organisation
des événements dans la manière
finalement de l'est de désigner les pays
qui organise
il ya aussi cette dimension géopolitique
il suffit de voir l'adhésion par exemple
des français à l'équipe nationale de
hand pour comprendre qu'il ya aussi
cette dimension de handball doit se
renouveler doit s'internationaliser et
ça ça passera par un changement de
paradigme
au niveau mondial on est sur un sport
qui a une vraie importance à l'échelle
mondiale et là où je suis d'accord c'est
que la globalisation du hand à l'est pas
encore achevée la politique à travers le
handball c'est ses doigts tu dois être
une politique pour le handball est plus
la politique pour la politique
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
alors ce coup-ci cet interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres aux ouvert sur les
siècles passés
les contempler ces découvrir le regard
que portent les artistes sur leur époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet et sept
enfants couverts de toute la tendresse
de sa mère peint par elisabeth vigée
lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
donald trump est à l'affût de 5
milliards enfin en tout cas preuve pour
une première tranche de travaux dont la
barrière n'est pas totalement construite
la totalité de la frontière c'est plus
de 3000 km le président des états unis
reprend le discours qu'il avait comme
candidats présentant les migrants comme
des vecteurs de délinquance de
criminalité le trafic de drogue
il est certain que la majorité des
migrants et mexicains ou centres
américains qui sont aux etats-unis ne
sommes pas là pour faire du trafic de
drogue mais pour travailler
[Musique]
il est 20h30 heure française merci de
nous rejoindre en direct sur rt france
pour décrypter l'actualité nous sommes
avec sébastien chenu porte parole du
rassemblement national député du nord
candidat également à la mairie de denain
c'est notre vanité politique ce soir
bonsoir sébastien chenu merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
commence avec l'actualité française
toujours dominé évidemment par la
mobilisation contre le projet de réforme
des retraites avec la prise de parole
aujourd'hui d'emmanuel macro quelle est
votre réaction le président qui comprend
les inquiétudes mais qui est prêt voilà
à discuter mais tout de même qu'ils ne
lâchent pas qui est déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout de cette réforme
je pense qu'il n'est pas dans l'adn
emmanuel macron de se remettre en cause
et que tout ça ce sont des rideaux de
fumée
ce sont des artifices le président de la
république française a choisi de
déconstruire le modèle social des
français donc il peut communiquer il
peut mettre un âge pivot le retirer le
suspendre la réalité c'est qu'il
instaurera cette retraite à points
parce qu'il a décidé de l'intérêt de 2,2
delà de la bête remplacé parce qu'il a
décidé de servir des intérêts qu'ils
n'étaient pas ceux des français mais des
intérêts de grands groupes
il leur ouvre la porte à la retraite par
capitalisation
on le voit bien à travers cette retraite
qui n'est aujourd'hui ce projet retraite
ni juste ni universel vous croyez pas
tout de même qui a une part de sincérité
de la part du gouvernement qui nous dit
tout simplement que notre système des
retraites n'est pas viable ainsi avec le
nombre d'actifs avec la démographie qui
aura plus assez de gens pour payer voilà
les retraites des plus âgés ça c'est
quelque chose que vous rejetez au
rassemblement national on n'a pas besoin
vraiment de réforme absolument nous nous
avons considéré mais pas seulement nous
un certain nombre d'économistes
y compris d'ailleurs l'ancien ministre
du budget de françois hollande qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui les capacités à
pérenniser ce système des retraites
capacité financière le déficit du
système de retraites est tout à fait
capable d'être compensée par un certain
nombre de réserves de fonds de réserve
qui existe actuellement
et puis surtout une autre politique à
mener sur le sauvegarder notre système
de retraite dans le présent dans le
public il ne souhaite pas sauvegarder
notre système de retraite il souhaite le
déconstruire pour aller vers une
retraite à points à partir du moment où
on veut sauvegarder le système de
retraite
on va vers une politique du patriotisme
économique de la réindustrialisation du
pays
on va aussi vers une politique de
la natalité encourager les français à
faire plus d'enfants pour que demain
évidemment il y ait plus d'actifs pour
payer les retraites de ceux qui partent
en retraite c'est de levier natalité et
patriotisme économique
emmanuel macron ne les utilise pas parce
que ce n'est pas son objectif que de
pérenniser notre système de retraite oui
bien sûr qu'ils aient la possibilité de
pérenniser ce système de retraite et
qu'on soit bien clair quand vous nous
dites on peut aller chercher l'argent
dans les fonds de de reiser se veut dire
quand vous allez par exemple on parlait
beaucoup et de celle des avocats
quand il ya 100 millions d'oeufs de
raies de dire sinon une première qu'on
combat il faut aller piquer par exemple
dans ce ce genre de fonds de retraite ou
à neil young
il est aujourd'hui deux types de
financement possibles pour compenser le
déficit des retraites
vous avez l'unedic et la branche famille
qui vont redevenir excédentaire 3
milliards et 5 milliards de mémoire donc
à vous avez 8 milliards qui compense à
peu près le déficit déjà des retraites
et puis après vous avez un fonds
alimenté par le crds et par la csg qui
sont aujourd'hui qui est aujourd'hui
mobilisables qui est la vocation est
provisoire je me rappelle qu'ils avaient
vocation à être provisoire monde est
bien content finalement peut-être de le
trouver et qui à peu près d'une
trentaine de milliards d'euros
donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas la
nécessité aujourd'hui de crier au loup
le gouvernement a voulu affoler les
français et c'est une technique on a
bien connu il affole les français
ensuite il agite la technique du pivot
ce qui permet à tous les syndicats de se
montrer hostile puis en fait après il
lâche sur le pivot les syndicats amis du
gouvernement est bien enclenché la
marche avec lui les autres passent pour
les méchants
le front syndical est brisé et le
gouvernement peut faire passer tout le
reste c'est à dire la retraite à points
en ayant enlevé le pivot alors marine le
pen souhaite un référendum depuis le
début d'ailleurs elle l'a rappelé encore
une fois ce matin dans le même temps un
jordan bardella expliqué que votre parti
retirer cette réforme si le parti si
votre parti arrivé au pouvoir en 2000
22e on a du mal à comprendre exactement
quels seraient l'intitulé tout
simplement de ce référendum
vous savez un référendum on y répond par
oui ou non
donc il est temps que le gouvernement
couche sur le papier sa réforme des
retraites qui nous donne exactement le
texte qui le souhaitent soumettre au
front soumettre aux français comme
d'ailleurs dans le passé j'ai dit
référendum un de référendum sur
maastricht était pas un
c'était un texte qui était difficile
d'accès et pourtant les français se sont
passionnés on a répondu oui ou non à ce
texte et bien c'est la même chose
nous demandons au gouvernement de mettre
sur le papier ce texte est les français
sauront répondre par oui ou non sur ce
texte sur cette réforme des retraites
et je pense que ça plusieurs objectifs
d'abord ça permet aux français de
trancher
on voit bien que payés bloquée et ça
permet de débloquer le pays parce que on
annonce qu'un référendum immédiatement
les grèves seraient levés les partisans
du pour les partisans du non on ferait
assauts de débats expliquerait leur
position expliquerait également comme je
le fais la capacité à sauvegarder le
régime des retraites
et puis les français trancheront le
gouvernement ne veut pas parce qu'il
sait qu'il va échouer sur un tel
référendum
ils s'étaient français sont hostiles à
ce texte le gouvernement a peur des
français ils sont hostiles et peut-être
parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris qui a
énormément de confusion il est vrai que
peu de français savent exactement quelle
sauce ils vont être mangés avec cette
réforme là n'est pas là le vrai coeur du
problème de cette réforme et par le fait
de réformer en lui même c'est qu'on ne
sait tout simplement parce que comment
les choses vont tourner pour nous chacun
je pense que les français ont très bien
compris que leur pension à les baisser
la retraite par points il suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs en
suède 92% des retraites ont baissé ça
les français l'ont très bien compris
après le fait que le gouvernement ne
soit pas en capacité d'organiser des
projections financières de 5 en capacité
de nous expliquer avec des mécanismes
voilà des études d'impact ou combien les
français pourront toucher lorsqu'il se
rend la retraite individuellement selon
leur cas là aussi des montres
l'impréparation total de ceux de ce
gouvernement sur ce sur cette réforme
des retraites je rappelle qu'ils
menaient le maquereau avec 1m dit lors
du débat sur la présidentielle qu'ils ne
reviendraient pas sur l'âge de départ à
la retraite elle macron a menti aux
français
et il continue alors il retire quand
même cette histoire d'âge qui vaut pas
écouté c'est un subterfuge et je vous ai
expliqué que tout ça
était cousu de fil blanc l'objectif de
macron s'est passée la retraite par
points je note d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
retiré aussi un certain nombre de
critères sur la pénibilité la pénibilité
ça fait partie des axes très important
de cette réforme des retraites par
exemple des critères qui sont très
basiques porter des poids des choses
comme ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui
portent des poids dans leur métier des
aides soignants des manipulateurs en
radiologie des gens qui ceux qui
travaillent dans l'industrie dans les
supermarchés etc
ils ont retiré ce type de critères donc
on voit bien que cette retraite elle
n'est pas juste et puis ils ont laissé
d'ailleurs se multiplier il nous avait
dit elle sera universelle devra tout le
monde sera dans le même régime pas du
tout il y aura plusieurs régimes et on
peut le comprendre d'ailleurs moi
j'arrive à comprendre qu'il y ait des
régimes particuliers parce qu'il ya des
situations particulières et parce que
tous les métiers ne se ressemblent pas
mais ces gouvernements étaient partis la
fleur au fusil en disant vous allez voir
ça va être plus juste ça va être
universel tout ça coûtera pas plus cher
on en est déjà à 10 à 15 milliards de
plus que les visites de retraite qui est
ce qu'aujourd'hui vous soutenez après 41
jours de grève c'est syndicats les plus
déterminés cgt unsa fo est ce qu'il faut
continuer à bloquer le pays et notamment
les parisiens qui souffre effectivement
je sais de g je comprends tout à fait la
souffrance des parisiens des habitants
des grandes villes des commerçants aussi
également qu'ils subissent tout ceci moi
l'idée n'est pas de soutenir des
syndicats mon boulot n'est pas de
soutenir des syndicats notre boulot
invité du rassemblement national
oui c'est de faire des propositions nous
en faisons des propositions sur le fond
et des progressions sur la forme pour
sortir des greffes d'ailleurs nous
avions proposé qu'il y ait une trêve
les syndicats n'ont pas souhaité qu'on
met sur la cgt nous voulons le retrait
de ce texte parce que ce texte il tape
méchamment les français il va leur faire
mal à terme donc aujourd'hui il ya des
manifestations il y à des blocages là ce
sont les seules façons dans une
démocratie de pouvoir se faire entendre
face à un pouvoir qui est tout à fait
sourd à ce que lui demande les français
retirer ce texte alors mobilisation dans
la rue également avec parfois on l'a vu
aussi lors les manifestations de gilet
jaune des violences policières en tout
cas des violences aussi des manifestants
en tout cas selon les opinions bien
souvent aujourd'hui les proches de ce
livreur cédric joue via
mort à paris après son interpellation
par les policiers le 3 janvier a été
reçu par christophe castaner se sont
déclarés extrêmement déçu parce que les
agents n'ont pas été suspendues vous
partager leurs sentiments
mais comment ne pas partager le
sentiment de cette famille à laquelle on
pense qui a dû enterrer l'un des siens
je note d'ailleurs que la famille en
question a dit qu'elle n'en voulait pas
à l'ensemble de la police nationale
qu'elle en voulait à ce qu'ils avaient
et bien fait en sorte que leur leur fils
leur frère meurt mais qu'elle n'en
voulait pas la police nationale il ya
des actes qui sont intolérables de dans
la police nationale on le voit
d'ailleurs les policiers même ne cherche
pas à le cacher il souhaite que la
lumière soit faite parce que c'est
l'image de marque également de la police
de notre pays et puis de l'autre côté
vous avez la paupérisation total 17
police
il faut bien se pencher sur les causes
de tout cela vous avez une police qui
est à bout une police ce qu'on a laissé
et qu'on laisse encore se faire taper
dessus dans certains quartiers je pense
également aux pompiers d'ailleurs qu'ils
sont dans les mêmes situations
donc à partir du moment où on veut des
professionnels qui fasse respecter
l'ordre façon républicaine ils le font
très majoritairement il faut aussi leur
donner des moyens on ne peut pas laisser
notre peau lisse paupérisée comme elle
le fait et puis avoir ce genre de fait
divers régulièrement d'accidents et et
qui font qu'ils sensibilisent évidemment
tous les français mais la clé de tout
cela c'est avoir une police qui soit
doté de moyens qui n'est pas des
millions d'heures supplémentaires à
rattraper qui ne soit pas au bout du
rouleau
et puis évidemment faire en sorte que la
police puisse accomplir partout sa
mission car je note qu'il ya des
endroits où il est parfois plus facile
de donner un coup de matraque d'autres
effectivement il ya des quartiers dans
lesquels on va pas on ne va plus parce
qu'il n'a pas les moyens alors que sur
les gilets jaunes
évidemment c'est plutôt facile de taper
fort est-ce qu'on a clairement encore
peur de l'uniforme dans ce pays est ce
que la police ait respecté évidemment
bien à part ce n'avoir rien à voir se
voit la mort de cédric jovial mais dans
le même temps est ce que les policiers
eux aussi ne sont pas des victimes et un
policier qui est mort à lyon cette
semaine
je pense que les français sont attachés
à leurs forces de l'ordre ils l'ont
démontré où ça il ya quelques années
avec charlie les français étaient tous
dans la rue pour dire qu'ils avaient
leur police les applaudir et 120 oui le
problème c'est qu'à police est devenue
une cible pour certains alors ce sont
souvent les mêmes
les voyous les racailles d'extrême
gauche les voyous les caïds de quartier
les dealers qui eux ne respectent rien
les black blocks
tous ces gens là qui sont nous avait dit
christophe castaner parfaitement
identifiés visiblement ils rentrent chez
eux tranquillement le soir après avoir
tabassé des flics et bien écoutez cette
situation n'est pas admissible où on
identifie les fauteurs de troubles et on
les sanctionne avec la rapidité et la
sévérité qu il se doit
ou alors on aura une police qui sera à
bout et on verra se multiplier des
accidents dans notre pays et tout le
monde que race et accidents les
municipales également qui approche à
grands pas vous êtes vous-même candidat
alors selon des informations de nos
confrères du figaro
d'ici au scrutin de mars le maquereau
nice julien de normandie prévoit de se
rendre dans des villes gouverné par
votre parti soit une tournée qu'on a
qualifié de antilles est reine il n'est
pas candidat lui même une réaction
peut-être oui monsieur de normandie qui
est un énarque qui va découvrir la vie
réelle en intéressant dans les villes et
les villages de france devrait
d'ailleurs puisqu'ils les ministres
démissionner immédiatement de son mandat
de ministre en fin de sa fonction
ministérielle puisqu'il est payé par les
français jusqu'à preuve du contraire il
est pas payé pour aller mener la guerre
au rassemblement national c'est la seule
chose qui d'ailleurs les obsède y
feraient mieux d'aller trouver des
candidats pour marges plutôt que
d'essayer d'aller piquer chez les
socialistes ou chez les républicains des
candidats les déguiser les repeindre en
marcheurs parce qu'ils n'ont pas
eux-mêmes
moi je trouve ça tout à fait ridicule
pour tout vous dire
ces gens là ne sont obsédés que par le
rassemblement national
elles sont passées de romandie n'est pas
obsédé par le chômage il n'est pas
obsédé par la paupérisation où je
l'invite à venir à denain 38 % de
chômeurs 48% de pauvreté il a peut-être
un discours à nous tenir monsieur de
normandie l'énarque de bercy plutôt que
de dire il faut pas voter pour le
rassemblement national parce que dans
les villes du rassemblement national et
bien votre de plus en plus pour le
rassemblement national parce que les
habitants sont heureux de la façon dont
leur ville et gérez vous dites ils
feraient mieux d'aller chercher des
candidats la république en marche alors
il se trouve qu'effectivement amer sur
deux ne se représentera pas ces passants
pub pour personne de trouver des
candidats notamment et rennes vous avez
fait le plein vous vous avez trouvé tous
vos candidats à bord on trouve jamais
tous les candidats qu'on aimerait
pouvoir trouver mais on a beaucoup de
dellys sur tout le pays tous les chefs
de départements auront une liste du
rassemblement national de nombreuses
villes de plus de 10 mille habitants je
crois que devenir élu local
c'est difficile et qu'aujourd'hui on
voit bien quels que soient les partis
politiques il y a des difficultés à
trouver des candidats
la tâche est ingrate elle est mal
considéré elle est peu payés alors maire
est centrale alors que le berger sont
certainement l'un des personnages
politiques les plus absolus bonifiant
ainsi le préféré défense c'est vrai et
l'état central le gouvernement laisse
beaucoup de mères seules face aux
problèmes moi j'ai un maire dans ma
circonscription à main qui a failli
perdre la vie parce qu'il s'opposait à
des gens du voyage comme on dit
pudiquement c'est à dire à des voyous
finalement qui voulait simplement
s'installer sur des terrains sans
autorisation donc la fonction mère elle
est difficile on voit pas de soutien du
gouvernement
les dotations baisse régulièrement les
maires ne sont pas protégés ils sont mal
indemnisés ils sont le réceptacle de
toutes les deux bandes des français donc
c'est difficile parfois de trouver des
candidats
en ce qui concerne le rassemblement
national nous nourrissons quelques beaux
espoirs les financements les finances on
en parle souvent du rassemblement
national est ce que c'est pas un
handicap dans la dans la campagne de ces
municipales être un parti pauvres est
effectivement un handicap
nous nous sommes riches en électeurs et
pauvres financièrement mais il faut dire
que le gouvernement a décidé d'essayer
de nous faire plier par ce biais là
d'essayer en ou réclamant des millions
d'euros d'essayer de nous mettre à
genoux parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
nous battre dans les urnes mais nous ne
plierons pas nos idées d'ailleurs nous
dépasse ce n'est pas simplement des
structures politiques qui portent des
idées nos idées elle nous dépasse elles
sont ancrées dans le pays
nous sommes la première opposition à
chaque fois qu'on a demandé aux français
de voter depuis 20 ans elle mâcon ils
nous ont placés en tête
alors justement ces municipales qui ont
lieu dans un contexte particulier nous
france fracturé est-ce que selon vous ça
va être le là ça va donner le lan de la
présidentielle
elles sont connues un pur pas forcément
être un vote sanction c'est municipal
mais ce qu elle pourrait le devenir
justement cette année en 2020 oui vous
savez c'est le fils
michel onfray qui disait emmanuel macron
c'est le président de la fin de la
france à vienne et la fin de la france
aef ayem eh bien je crois que les
municipales sont l'occasion de dire que
oui nous voulons une france qui soit qui
demeure ce qu'elle est avec nos villages
avec l'identité de nos villes et puis
oui nous voulons une france qui soit
prospère et dynamique et reprendre le
contrôle de nos vies et moselle mc on
sait ce président du désordre absolu qui
n'aiment pas les villages de france qui
n'aiment pas les bourgades de france
vous avez ce sentiment quand même
manière les visages complètement hors
sol c'est un président que ce débat
lancé à la communication mais c'est un
président des métropoles c'est l'homme
des métropoles toutes ces politiques
sont en faveur des métropoles moi qui
suis un élu du nord
je vous le dis à lille vous avez accès à
tous à la santé à la culture aux
transports à l'éducation très facilement
venez à 40 km dans nos villes comme
denain etc et vous verrez si cet accès
il est aussi facile alors que ce sont
les mêmes français à qui on doit les
mêmes choses si ce n'est plus davantage
d'ailleurs si ce n'est plus parfois
pour finir quels sont vos objectifs au
rassemblement national pour ces
élections alors pas d'objectifs chiffrés
par ce que d'ailleurs personne ne peut
en avoir très honnêtement parce que l'
éclatement total des forces politiques
aujourd'hui nous avait dit ne pas savoir
si on se retrouvera à 2 à 3 à 4 au
second tour nous évidemment c'est de
voir nos mères réélu un douzaine de
maires que nous avons réélu et 2 x x ce
nombre de maires et ce nombre de
conseillers municipaux
je crois que nous sommes bien partis
merci beaucoup sébastien chenu d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
porte parole du rassemblement national
et député du nord et vous l'avez dit
candidat à la mairie de denain dans le
nord
cette information qui vient tout juste
de nous parvenir une explosion majeure a
eu lieu ce soir en espagne
la déflagration a provoqué un incendie
dans l'usiné pétrochimique hickox près
de la ville de tarragone faisant au
moins un mort et quatre blessés
la protection civile a sommé la
population vivant à proximité de la zone
de ne pas quitter leur domicile nous
reviendrons évidemment sur cette
information un petit peu plus tard dans
cette émission le dossier iranien
présent la france l'allemagne et le
royaume uni tentent de contraindre
l'iran ils ont déclenché les procédures
leur permettant de forcer téhéran à
respecter ses engagements sur le
nucléaire les explications de valentin
carpentier
si les états unis veulent de plus en
plus de sanctions l'europe menace ait
choisi la voie de la contrainte
les trois pays européens cosignataire de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien sont
montés au créneau pour mettre la
pression sur l'iran pour y parvenir la
france l'allemagne et le royaume uni ont
déclenché le mécanisme de règlement des
différends prévu dans le texte afin
d'obliger téhéran à respecter ses
engagements
nous n'avons plus d'autre choix étant
donné les mesures prises par l'iran que
de faire part aujourd'hui de nos
préoccupations quant au fait que l'iran
ne respecte pas ses engagements au titre
du gie cypihot et et de saisir la
commission conjointe dans le cadre du
mécanisme de règlement des différends
conformément aux dispositions du parade
à 36 ipo et ce faisant nos trois pays ne
rejoignent pas la campagne visant à
exercer une pression maximale contre
l'iran nous agissons en toute bonne foi
avec l'objectif primordial de préserver
l'accord et dans l'espoir sincère de
trouver une solution pour sortir de
l'impasse
par le biais d'un dialogue diplomatique
constructif tout en restant dans son
cadre nous espérons ramener l'iran au
plein respect des engagements au titre
du g6 pihouet annoncé depuis plusieurs
semaines par paris le mécanisme de
règlement des différends a finalement
été lancée et pourrait mener à terme au
rétablissement des sanctions de l'onu
levée après 2015 l'europe c'est pourtant
prononcé contre des sanctions et
souhaite sauver la corde 2015 dans mais
cela va à l'encontre de la volonté de
donald trump qui a demandé aux européens
de se retirer
boris johnson s'est quant à lui dit
favorable au remplacement de l'accord de
vienne par un texte proposé par le
président américain le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josette borel a
tenu à réaffirmer qu'aucune sanction ne
seraient émises envers l'iran l'objectif
du mécanisme de règlement des différends
n'est pas de ré imposé des sanctions il
propose que ce mécanisme vise à résoudre
les problèmes liés à la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord dans le cas de la commission
mixte je pense qu'il doit être clair que
l'objectif est donc de trouver des
solutions et de revenir au plein respect
dans le cadre de cet accord le mécanisme
de règlement des différends exige un
effort intensif de bonne foi de tous les
membres
et en tant que coordinateur je m'attends
à ce que tous les participants au
processus la mort dans cet état d'esprit
que nous devons préserver l'accord sur
le nucléaire tu peux travailler pour
revenir à une mise en oeuvre complète
efficace tôt faut un effectif
de son côté l'iran a répondu et a mis en
garde berlin londres et paris contre les
conséquences de cette décision
cette déclaration ce matin du président
iranien l'iran doit punir tous les
responsables de la catastrophe aérienne
du boeing craignant justice iranienne a
par ailleurs annoncé plusieurs
arrestations le rappel 176 passagers et
membres d'équipage ont perdu la vie
mercredi dernier après qu'un avion d'une
compagnie ukrainienne a été abattu par
erreur par un missile iranien
samedi les forces armées iraniennes ont
reconnu leur responsabilité
le soir même une cérémonie d'hommage aux
victimes et à la manifestation contre
les autorités aux cris de mort aux
menteurs président rien cet incident
était sans précédent dans l'histoire de
notre pays
il n'y a jamais eu un moment où un
responsable de nos systèmes de défense
aérienne où un officier a commis une
telle erreur contre un avion de
passagers dans la capitale du pays
au centre du pays et près de l'aéroport
international tout en me rapprochant des
familles qui ont été frappés par cette
grande tragédie
je leur dis que nous continuerons sur
cette voie jusqu'à découvrir tous les
aspects de l'incident et punir les
personnes impliquées et enfin rassurer
les gens qu'un tel incident ne se
reproduira plus
regarde en guinée deux manifestants tués
hier lors d'une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation
une journée marquée par les
affrontements avec les forces de l'ordre
les manifestants répondaient à l'appel
de l'opposition pour dénoncer le projet
prêté au président alpha condé de
briguer un troisième mandat fin 2020 en
trois mois de contestation au moins 20
civils et un gendarme ont été tués lors
des rassemblements de quoi sur la
situation avec hélène masquelier depuis
près de trois mois les manifestations se
multiplient dans la capitale guinéenne
la cause de ces protestations un projet
de nouvelle constitution proposée par le
président alpha condé
j'ai engagé le processus d'élaboration
d'une nouvelle constitution tirant les
leçons de notre passé politique et
institutionnelle et en permettant à
notre nation de faire face aux défis des
temps présents et futurs
une nouvelle constitution qui
permettrait au président guinéen de
briguer un troisième mandat fin 2020
alpha condé ne s'est pas encore exprimé
sur ses intentions
mais pour l'opposition le front national
de défense de la constitution l'objectif
est clair et les contestataires crient
au coup d'état institutionnel
on reste quand même le principe d'une
nouvelle constitution
donc on parle de la quel que soit ce
qu'il m'est pas là dedans cela ne
regarde plus la nouvelle construction
on n'avait pas
nous avons c'est une procédure est
légale une passion que c'est illégal
on ne va pas l'accompagner d'aller c'est
un chiffon c'était intentions qu'on
propose au peuple souverain de guinée
fait rentrer les copains et les copines
dans le seul but de satisfaire les
desiderata et les la force nature du
prêt de ses complices acer à notre
niveau nous pensons qu'elle est une tête
toute vie simplement de la diversion de
la comédie il hier les guinéens se sont
de nouveau mobiliser massivement
mais le gouvernement hui organise sa
riposte il ya deux jours l'exécutif
avait averti la population envers ceux
qui veulent troubler leur public est né
aux autres dîner libre exercice de
jeunes manifestants ont été tués hier au
cours de la manifestation et l'agenda
politique est chargé des élections
législatives prévues mi février et
l'élection présidentielle à la fin de
l'année la communauté internationale
redoute une escalade des tensions dans
un pays connu pour son usage excessif de
la force à l'encontre des manifestants
elle est née de la situation en guinée
avec sidy hansen est journaliste
indépendant le problème du gouvernement
et du président alpha condé lui-même
sait que ils ne font que renforcer ces
soupçons
il n'y a absolument aucun mot aucun même
pas sensibilisation sur cette
reconstitution dont on connaît le
contenu il ya seulement enfin depuis
seulement un mois
or ça fait bientôt maintenant un an que
le gouvernement et le pouvoir ne cesse
de faire la promotion d'un texte dont on
ignorait absolument tout jusqu'en
décembre dernier
donc il faut dire que les propos
belliqueux que tu tiennes bas que tient
aussi faut le dire le premier des
guinéens le président alpha condé qui
tient des propos de plus en plus graves
où il fait créé lui-même une fracture au
sein de la guinée est aussi là
l'opposition et
l'as taissy vie qui se radicalise qui
demandent désormais le départ pur et
simple du causal faconde et plutôt que
de demander simplement le retrait du
texte du projet de texte comme comme
comme il le faut jusqu'à présent on sent
bien que là les choses cantons sont en
train de se radicaliser et les morts je
le crains avons continué à s'accumuler
sur le sur le pays guinée en reste avec
nous dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la crise du milieu
hospitalier en france des médecins qui
menacent de démissionner de façon
collective si des mesures ne sont pas
prises face à de nouvelles accusations
de violences policières emmanuel macron
demande au ministère de l'intérieur des
propositions très concrètes pour
améliorer la déontologie des forces de
l'ordre
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis l'actionnaire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france yelle parfois on
n'a que des éléphanteaux victimes de
braconnage particulièrement brutale car
malheureusement les bébés sont souvent
témoin non seulement du meurtre de leur
mère mais aussi la voix se faire
massacrer des coupes et brochettes a dû
je crois que les éléphants sourient
c'est ce que je vois chez des petits
leurs expressions faciales change
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
j'avais au coq sundown c'est un conte
pour les gens qui ne peuvent pas être
exposé au soleil
ils me disent c'est donc un camp pour
les vampires je crois que c'est commence
entre l'hébergement pour repère non pas
à parler de tout ce qu'ils traversent
parce que nous comprenons tous notre
fille katie a été diagnostiqué d'une
maladie très rare d'hypersensibilité au
soleil si j'ai un coup de soleil je
guéris elle elle ne guérit pas elles ont
aussi des problèmes moteurs des
problèmes d'élocution et d'audition le
volume du cerveau diminue nettement le
crâne grandi et le cerveau rapetisse il
est impossible de décrire cette douleur
c'est comme une brûlure chimiques très
très grave
la douleur passe dans la peau du muscle
jusqu'aux os c'est impossible à soulager
parfois nous sommes mis à l'épreuve non
pour montrer nos faiblesses mais pour
découvrir nos forces
[Musique]
geoffroy et loïc deux frères aventuriers
ont décidé de suivre le cours du
troisième plus grand fleuve du monde
les yankees notre objectif est simple
aller à la rencontre d'un fleuve
mythique qui telle une artère irrigue le
pays le plus peuplé au monde
cette source en cinq mois de sa source
sur les hauts plateaux tibétains à son
embouchure à shanghai ils ont parcouru
plus de 7000 km à moto et en tricycle à
la découverte du lien qui unit l'homme à
l'eau
[Musique]
k
oh
nous filons à toute allure vers de
nouvelles rencontres et des paysages qui
sans aucun doute vont encore beaucoup
nous surprendre
[Musique]
la rivière tout mme boyd chiot au delà
du cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du trouble la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
21h merci nous rejoint pour cette
deuxième heure d'émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi de ce mardi même actualité sociale
chargée en france la contestation contre
la réforme des retraites se poursuit le
milieu hospitalier lui ne désarment pas
contre la réforme et contre les
conditions de travail 1200 médecins ont
démissionné aujourd'hui de leurs
fonctions administratives un geste fort
après des mois de mobilisation pour
dénoncer l'insuffisance du plan
d'urgence de la ministre de la santé
dévoilé fin novembre des propositions
pour améliorer la déontologie des
policiers des gendarmes c'est la demande
formulée par emmanuel macron alors que
la police fait face à plusieurs
accusations de violences lors des
dernières manifestations ou dans la
sphère cédric joue via le président qui
a rappelé que les forces de sécurité
intérieure en sont aussi les premières
victimes
c'est le premier revenant djihadiste
français libéré de prison s'était hier
après sept ans d'incarcération alors
qu'une grosse trentaine de libération
sont attendus cette année quel suivi
pour ces détenus condamnés pour
terrorisme
sont ils des ex prisonniers comme les
autres ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
après 41 jours de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites le gouvernement se
tourne vers le compromis en déplacement
à pau emmanuel macron a réagi en
souhaitant l'apaisement une directive
suivi par le gouvernement et le groupe
la république en marche et précision
avec florian lambert après 41 jours de
mobilisation le gouvernement souhaite
apaiser se tourner vers le compromis
trois jours après l'offre d'edouard
philippe de retirer sous condition l'âge
pivot du projet c'est emmanuel macron
lui même qui a pris la parole ce mardi à
pau comme pour apaiser les tensions
qu'il faut avec beaucoup de calme
maintenant de clarté que notre pays
rentre dans cet état d'esprit payer
quand on quand on prend la peine
d'expliquer calmement et d'écouté on
peut lever beaucoup d'ambiguïtés
malentendu on ne lèvera pas le
mécontentement pour le premier ministre
edouard philippe la conférence de
financement permettra de résoudre le
conflit
je pense que la conférence de
financement réunissant les partenaires
sociaux proposera à la fin de ses
travaux une mesures d'âge afin
d'équilibrer le système des retraites
même son de cloche du côté du
gouvernement et du groupe la république
en marche
tous les éléments sont en place pour que
cette grève se termine et notamment le
fait qu'aucun grévistes ne peut
aujourd'hui se sentir humilié par la
manière dont se conclut ce conflit le
jusqu'au boutisme n'est pas une solution
la réforme des retraites portée par le
gouvernement va garantir un régime de
retraite par répartition plus juste et
permettre à des milliers de français
d'avoir une retraite minimum à 1000
euros
et pourtant la mobilisation ne semble
pas faiblir
plusieurs centaines de personnes ont
défilé mardi à paris en répondant à
l'appel des syndicats cgt fo solidaires
et fsu et dans le cortège le compromis
ne semble pas être le mot d'ordre la
réforme est venu au bon point pour
remobiliser les gens en finale parce que
les gens se rendent compte comment ça se
passe vraiment dans les manifestations
et le peu de réponses que nous apporte
quand on manifeste pour quelque chose
sur laquelle on n'est pas d'accord
même les grévistes qui avaient pas
encore participé aux rigides et jaunes
et qui avait l'habitude de manifester
avant se rendent compte de tout ce qui
est en train de passer ce gouvernement
veut passer le maximum de réformes et a
pu avoir besoin de revenir là dessus
donc c'est très dangereux jean luc
mélenchon a annoncé mardi qu'il
proposait le dépôt d'une motion de
censure contre le gouvernement
le chef de file des députés insoumis
veut s'allier avec les députés du parti
communiste et le groupe des socialistes
pour mener à bien l'opération
nous allons proposer au groupe
communistes et socialistes de déposer
une motion de censure contre son
gouvernement
quel est le sens de voter sur un texte à
trous qui n'est pas complet le
gouvernement doit être mis au pied de
ses responsabilités sur la réforme des
retraites
à dix jours de la présentation du projet
de loi en conseil des ministres
la tension qui accompagne la réforme des
retraites permet difficilement
d'envisager la voie du compromis aussi
s'opposent à cette réforme des retraites
les employés de l'hôpital public
le collectif inter hôpitaux a tenu
plusieurs conférences de presse
l'occasion pour les médecins
hospitaliers de rendre publique la
lettre de démission collective de leurs
responsables et administratives
conférence de presse notamment la pitié
salpêtrière à paris les précisions de
notre reporter sonnen gaudin
démissionner de leurs fonctions
administratives c'est l'ultime recours
de ces mille médecins pour sauver
l'hôpital public à bout de souffle
je vous propose de les écouter on ne
remplace pas les départs à la retraite
août face au retard des on ne remplace
pas les congés de maternité ont créé des
superstructures au mutualiser des
soignants ont changé leurs horaires on
n'augmente pas les salaires le salaire
aujourd'hui des infirmières en france
est au 28e rang des 32 pays de l' ocde
nous demandons donc une revalorisation
des salaires des soignants et la
réintroduction des services au centre de
la gouvernance de l'hôpital nous
démissionnons parce que nous voulons
sauver notre bien commun qui est
l'hôpital public
nous implorons notre ministre agnès
buzyn qui connaît l'hôpital
est ce qu'il y a travaillé comme nombre
dans des années de relever enfin la tête
et de résister aux injonctions de bercy
soit on essaye de sauver l'hôpital
public avec la vision qu'avaient robert
debré en 1958 et qui avait permis à la
médecine française d'être classée au
premier rang mondial par l' oms au début
des années 2000 soit on revient
vers l'hôpital hospice du 19e siècle qui
prend en charge les pauvres les démunis
les autres ayant recours à la médecine
privée
alors concrètement que signifie cette
démission administrative et bien les
médecins l'assurent ils continueront les
soins et l'accueil des patients en
revanche plus de gestion de planning
plus de formulaires plus de réunion et
une démission qui prend effet
immédiatement
un message politique fort envoyé au
gouvernement dans le but de créer un
électrochoc au ministère de la santé
pour relancer les négociations sur le
budget et les salaires et pour en parler
nous sommes avec stéphane augé chef du
service de réanimation pédiatrique à
l'hôpital robert debré membres du
collectif inter hôpitaux bonsoir ses
fans dauger merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france c'était une journée
en tout cas forte en symbole est
importante pour le personnel hospitalier
vous étiez présent la conférence de
presse comment ça s'est passé
[Musique]
bonsoir on avait écouté la conférence de
presse s'est plutôt bien passé nous
avons tenu l'horaire comme nous avons
l'habitude de le faire
nous avons pu exposer l'ensemble des
problèmes de l'hôpital public et faire
témoigner des collègues d'hôpitaux
universitaires d'hôpitaux universitaires
c'est une représentante des usagers qui
a parlé en premier et qui a témoigné des
difficultés de l'hôpital public depuis
plusieurs années nous avons aussi
précisé quelles étaient les conséquences
de cette démission collective de plus de
100 buts maintenant mille trois cents
chefs de service et nous avons ensuite
répondu aux questions à la presse nous
étions très heureux d'avoir pu faire
cette conférence de presse qui s'est
déroulé comme nous l'avions prévu
'l'annonce votre annonce aujourd'hui at
elle eu l'effet escompté
écoutez à ma connaissance non pour
l'instant je ne crois pas qu'on ait eu
un contact avec le ministère de la santé
où le premier nous on attend d'en savoir
plus je viens d'apprendre il ya quelques
minutes que de nouveaux hôpitaux se
proposait de plusieurs chefs de service
d'autres hôpitaux donc d'autres chu qui
jusque là n'avait pas signé était prêt à
signer je dois être en contact avec eux
demain je pense que la pression continue
à monter j'espère que le ministère de la
santé va nous répondre rapidement et
qu'on va pouvoir sa table s'asseoir
autour d'une table de négociation pour
avancer très clairement pour construire
l'hôpital de demain où on le rappelle à
vous avez présenté votre démission
collective de vos responsabilités
administratives est ce que tous autant
que vous êtes vous êtes capable d'aller
jusqu'au bout de cette démission
réellement bien écoutez je pense que oui
mesdames parce que nous avions d'abord
pris des précautions nous réfléchissons
à cette deuxième étape qui est venue
après la rétention du codage si vous
vous souvenez bien nous avions
initialement arrêtées transmettre à
l'assurance maladie
loos puis le couple l'hospitalisation
des patients malgré cela nous n'avons
pas été entendus donc nous avions prévu
de cette émission nous avions prévenu
longtemps le nombre de démissionnaires a
augmenté très clairement sur les
dernières semaines nous avons expliqué à
chacun de nos collègues de bien
réfléchir d'en parler avec leurs équipes
d'en parler avec leurs futurs d'en
parler avec l'ensemble des collègues
avec qui travaille d'habitude pour être
bien sûr des conséquences de cet acte et
nous avons même relancé chacun d'entre
eux pour être certain qu'ils iraient
jusqu'au bout
à ma connaissance une seule personne a
dit que ça lui semblait compliqué a
préféré se retirer de la liste
ce pourquoi il a été aussi créer une
liste de soutien aux démissionnaires qui
ce matin avait à peu près 5000
signatures de personnes qui ne sont pas
chef de service mais qui soutiennent
notre geste
donc je pense très sincèrement que
l'ensemble des signataires l'ont fait en
conscience après avoir bien réfléchi et
iront jusqu'au bout et je vous dis
encore avant que nous clôturons cette
liste pour la donner à la presse il ya à
peu près 48 72 heures il y avait encore
à peu près 70 à 80 signatures de chef de
service de tous les hôpitaux publics
français qui signe et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est à 1352 gens qui
sont très motivés oui on rappelle
évidemment pour de téléspectateurs qui
n'auraient pas suivi qu'il ya eu un plan
un énième plan annoncé le 20 novembre en
quoi celui-ci rap et nous n'était encore
pas suffisant pour vous que demandez
vous concrètement aujourd'hui nos
revendications n'ont pas changé mais
d'abord nous sommes tout à fait
conscients de l'effort qui a été fait le
typiquement le rachat d'un tiers de la
dette des hôpitaux dont on aimerait
savoir exactement pourquoi ils se sont
endettés entre autres dans les marchés
financiers avec des risques majeurs mais
cette question est réglée maintenant que
le gouvernement rachète et que l'état
rachète un tiers de la dette des
hôpitaux c'est quelque chose d'important
il n'empêche que nos principales
revendications sont les suivantes et
vous les connaissez nous les
donnons au ministre de la santé depuis
déjà de nombreux mois
premièrement une augmentation de l'ondam
est du financement de la sécurité
sociale à 4 3% par rapport à l'année
précédente et pas 2,3 comme ça a été
concédée par le gouvernement sinon
d'emblée les hôpitaux se remettront à
être endetté dès les premiers mois de
l'année la réouverture de lits en aval
des urgences et en aval des soins aigus
si vous notez bien ça n'a jamais été
proposé par le gouvernement et la
revalorisation salariale des tout petits
salaires de la fonction publique
hospitalière
que ce soit les soignants les aides
soignantes les infirmières que soient
les techniciens les ouvriers les jeunes
médecins qui s'installent pour que les
médecins les paramédicaux l'ensemble des
personnels techniques et administratifs
il ne faut pas les oublier
soit avec nous et reste dans l'hôpital
public pour continuer à construire
l'hôpital de demain
à ce jour aucune de ses revendications
avaient été satisfaites on nous a
proposé des primes on nous a proposé
pour certains pas pour d'autres dans
certaines villes pas pour d'autres
ce n'est pas une mesure globale pour
l'hôpital public et non nous ne sommes
pas satisfaits aujourd'hui clairement ce
n'est pas un problème de système qu'il
faut revoir de fond en comble et arrêté
peut-être de colmater les brèches
alors nous nous sommes de fond en comble
je ne sais pas en tous les cas le
constat est que nous étions reconnus par
les instances internationales comme le
premier système de santé public en 2000
dans le monde et que nous sommes tombé
au sixième ou septième rang quelques
années il ya sans doute des choses à
changer les maladies ont évolué les
poubelles la population vieillit les
pathologies chroniques sont importantes
moi je suis pédiatre réanimateur
là aussi la pédiatrie a changé je pense
que nous sommes dans un métier comme
plein d'autres mais nous en sommes
1 dans lequel nous absorbons les
changements il nous sommes capables de
beaucoup de souplesse et flexibilité à
nous adapter
il n'empêche qu'il faut changer
effectivement le paradigme ce n'est plus
soigné au moins deux retours quoi qu'il
arrive c'est soigné au juste coût et
partir des besoins de la population et
certainement pas dans
une volonté d'économies à tout crin il
faut effectivement changer le système
pour qu'on regarde exactement ce dont
les gens ont besoin est là nous serons
prêts et c'est la motivation de
l'ensemble des soignants du tout les
personnels de l'hôpital public a avancé
très clairement s'il le faut dans une
nouvelle version de l'hôpital public
mais partant des besoins de la
population et pas l'inversé être des
mesures parfaitement dans son ce que
n'importe qui peut comprendre ce que
vous êtes en train de d'évoquer la que
vous répond la ministre
quand vous lui parlez comme ça
clairement je crois qu'on lui parle
enfin moi je m'étais avec elle que pour
une réunion suite aux difficultés des
bronchiolites et de l'épidémie hivernale
de la réanimation pédiatrique en
ile-de-france qui est un problème bien
limité par rapport à d'autres mais qui
est un très bon témoin de la gravité de
la situation
je pense que les messages ont été très
clair depuis longtemps vous le savez
sans doute les gériatres on le dit à
chaque fois les psychiatres depuis
longtemps les urgentistes depuis
quasiment bientôt un an
et puis l'ensemble de l'hôpital public
maintenant pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas des réponses à la hauteur
madame la ministre nous explique que son
plan est très bon et nous fait de la
communication de très bon niveau pour
nous expliquer que c'est le meilleur
choix
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça nous
voulons avancer et je pense que ce geste
qui nous a coûté beaucoup dont on
connaît l'importance démontre très bien
qu'il faut qu'on passe à autre chose on
veut s'asseoir il faut des gestes forts
sur nos principales revendications et
nous viendrons à la table pour
travailler sur la gouvernance du nouvel
hôpital avec les usages et les
paramédicaux l'ensemble des soignants
nous sommes prêts à ça nous avons envie
d'avancer il n'y a aucun doute là dessus
merci stéphane augé chef de service de
réanimation pédiatrique à l'hôpital
robert debré d'avoir pris le temps de
nous répondre en direct sur rt france
merci à vous et cette contestation
contre la réforme des retraites qui a
malheureusement été le théâtre de
violences policières emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé sur le sujet aujourd'hui
le président demande des propositions
pour améliorer la déontologie des
policiers et des gendarmes
souhaitant que la justice puisse
continuer à travailler sur ces cas il
met en garde contre les amalgames il
existe il insiste pardon sur des
violences dont je cite les forces de
sécurité intérieures sont les premières
victimes
et cette victime justement mortes à la
suite d'un contrôle de police
une information judiciaire a été ouverte
pour homicide involontaire famille et
avocat de cédric souvient parle d'une
bavure policière ils ont d'ailleurs été
reçu aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'intérieur cédric h ou bien 42 ans est
décédé le 3 janvier dernier après son
interpellation par des policiers à paris
il a été victime d'une asphyxie avec une
fracture du larynx après avoir été
plaqué au sol casque sur la tête par
plusieurs agents de police écoutez les
réactions déçu de l'un de ses fils à la
sortie de l'entretien il a répondu à
sartre et de questions mais bon on a
quand même on est quand même sorti en
manque de quelque chose en manque de
manque d'information voilà les policiers
nous notre principale question c'était
que qu'est ce que font les quatre
policiers qui ont interpellé au mon père
et il n'a pas été en mesure de nous
répondre
s'il était toujours en le service il
pouvait encore contrôler les gens alors
que airlines et que tant qu'il n'aurait
pas une information qui dirait que
l'interpellation et qu'elle a mon père
être provoquée par un de leurs ges
il ne pourrait pas les suspendre alors
que voilà ça va faire presque deux
semaines que c'est dit clairement dans
tous les journaux dans tous les articles
que mon père a été tué par une fracture
du larynx
donc il ya fait qui a provoqué une
asphyxie
donc après si ça pour ce n'est pas une
preuve qui montrent que les policiers
ont
et provoquer des actes envers mon père
déloyale et avec grande brutalité
je sais pas ce que je veux dire de plus
et c'est dans ce contexte qu'un autre
qu'une autre affaire de violence
policière a été classée sans suite par
le parquet de paris la semaine dernière
elle a gilet jaune mélanie damien
victime d'un coup de matraque à dans la
nuque réagi au micro d'rtl france un
sujet de katia technique le 20 avril
2019 légis les jeunes défilent à paris
lors d'une manifestation autorisée
mélanie une militante occupée à lire un
tract ne voit pas la charge de crs
derrière son dos elle est alors
violemment frappé par surprise par un
crs et elle s'effondre elle nous raconte
je suis seul où j'ai les bras levés j'ai
le papier dans la main un homme
fait 28 pas donc cours sur 30 mètres
arme son bras et massène un coup de
matraque dans la nuque
ces images signalé par le journaliste et
écrivain david dufresne provoque
l'indignation sur les réseaux sociaux
elles vont être visionnée plus d'un
million de fois mélanie travailleuse
sociale et porte-parole des gilets
jaunes damien les réfractaires du 80 se
souvient je perd connaissance à
plusieurs reprises tiré trois à quatre
fois que je me souviens de la douleur et
je me souviens d'après la douleur j'ai
eu une entorse des cervicales
j'ai les disques c4 et c5 qui sont morts
la légiste m'a dit que si jamais j'avais
pas eu cette écharpe
je serai étape tétraplégique à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui pour moi c'était même pas
envisageable que ce soit un homme qui
ait fait ça délibèrement je ne pouvais
pas l'imaginer parce que moi j'ai grandi
dans une famille où nous a donné des
valeurs de respect qu'un uniforme ça se
respecte et cette mère de famille porte
plainte contre x
mais surprise début janvier le parquet
de paris classé la plainte sans suite
selon la justice le choix du policier
dollar poussée lors de sa charge était
justifiée même si la blessure subie
n'était pas recherché
il a en outre jugé que la vitesse de
marche de la gilet jaune
allez la laisser derrière le nouveau
barrage qu'ils essayaient d'établir ce
qui était dangereux
cette décision a révolté plusieurs
personnalités et bien entendu mélanie
dans mon éducation deux quartiers
populaires c'est ce qu'on m'a appris ce
que mon père m'a transmis
tu ne cours pas tu n'as rien fait
mélanie tu ne cours pas il ya que les
délinquants qui courent et que ceux qui
ont quelque chose à se reprocher qui
courent moi je cours je la mets sait
jamais rien à me reprocher en fait mais
il ya un recours
on va aller jusqu'au bout on va les
saigner les recours tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire on le fera
mon but n'est pas de gagner de l'argent
c'est juste que quand une personne ne
tape le nom de mon agresseur dans google
y est pas toutes ses médailles parce
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ce monsieur
était même médaillé au mois de mai
mélanie affirme connaître l'identité du
crs en question le milieu militant crois
qu'il s'agit d'un homme déjà connu pour
des faits similaires il est important
que la police est une vraie police pour
les juger aujourd'hui
un policier qui lance un pavé qui ne
touche personne prend trois mois avec
sursis comme excuse
s'il fallait condamner quelqu'un c'était
une personne qui avait blessé un
manifestant un militant cette militante
n'est pas découragé de manifester et
continuer à fédérer les gilet jaune
d'amiens
pour elle il est nécessaire de ne pas
plier devant la peur au nom du combat
pour la justice sociale et pour en
parler nous sommes avec christophe
crépin porte parole du syndicat france
police bonsoir mon genre mais pas merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france quand vous entendez cet exil et
jaune s'exprimer est ce que vous vous
dites voilà il ya quand même du vrai il
ya un malentendu avec la police avec une
partie des citoyens déçus c'est un
malentendu avec la police bien sûr que
le mât parité syndicale dès le départ on
a dit qu'ils avaient une fracture
sociale qui avait des gens qui avaient
des doléances que tu est légitime
on était ouvert à tous sauf évidemment
aux violences qui ont été commises par
certaines personnes qui voulaient se
dire d'un gilet jaune mais qui était en
fait des black blocs qui venait prendre
les collègues on exulte toi mais en
effet notre pays connaît une fracture
sociale assez conséquente
c'est sans précédent si j'ose dire il ya
eu un avant et un après mouvement des
gilet jaune c'est ça qui a créé comme on
dit le grand malentendu et c'est un bon
résumé en fait il ya eu un avant et
après il ya eu il ya eu dans notre pays
une attente profonde au suffrage
universel c'est la raison pour laquelle
ils ont élu monsieur macron parce qu'ils
pensaient qu'il y aurait un changement
radical ce changement n'a pas fait jour
il ya des gens qui doivent choisir entre
faire le plein de leur véhicule et leur
plein de réfrigérateurs et des gens qui
ont vraiment une fracture sociale nous
mêmes les policiers nous avons une somme
citoyens policiers et nous avons des
fois le choix à faire entre faire le
plat notre véhicule pour aller au
travail et remplir le frigidaire
aujourd'hui vous vous trouvez dans une
position délicate
finalement parfois un policier sur ce
plateau ma vie dit le coeur à geaune le
coeur jaune voilà et finalement d'être
obligé d'être sur le terrain pour
remplir sa mission imagine que ça doit
être peut-être compliqué l'état d'esprit
des troupes actuellement c'est très
difficile surtout qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même où je fais l'interview
nous avons des propos de notre mini
c'est notre président de la république
qui ne satisfont pas du tout ma parité
syndicale justement donc j'allais bien
évidemment y venir emmanuel macron qui
s'est exprimé aujourd'hui notamment
aussi sur les retraites mais il a parlé
de ces violences policières avec cette
affaire show via dont on va parler
également le président qui demandent des
propositions pour améliorer la
déontologie votre réaction
mais on n'a pas entendu monsieur la
composante des anthologies la
déontologie nous avons un code de
déontologie qui ce qui se vit dans notre
profession nous sommes la profession la
plus contrôlée que ce soit il la police
ou la gendarmerie on est contrôlé à tous
les niveaux nous avons l'inspection
générale de la police
nous avons le parquet nous avons le
défenseur des droits systématiquement
dès qu'on a une vidéo
la hiérarchie nous convoque et nous
demandent des explications
on n'a pas attendu d'avoir ce genre de
déclaration qui pour moi une déclaration
politique et qu'il ne va pas
certainement pas aller dans le sens de
mes collègues c'était la même chose
d'ailleurs pour christophe castaner peu
le porte-parole de monsieur macro
monsieur castanheira mais c'est quand
même lui qui donne le la de dollars
c'est quand même votre patron à la
police donc on imagine que je le sais
mais j'aimerais bien que multon
souviennent qu on a besoin d'avoir un
patron qui sont ils prêts de ses troupes
en fait voilà justement vous estimez que
christophe castaner y est peut-être pour
quelque chose
voilà dans ces tensions j'ai le plus
profond respect à l'institution mon pays
du président de la république de
monsieur castaner nommant il faut pas
qu'ils oublient que la police nationale
et la gendarmerie nous traversons une
période qui est sans précédent et qui
est une période très difficile nous
avons attiré son attention par des
intersyndicales qui n'ont pas été
suivies d'effet
même sur les retraites nous sommes pas
aligner poli gendarmerie nous allons
nous sommes dans un désarroi total
le dernier collet qui a mis fin à ses
jours la mi parce qu'il ne se
reconnaissait plus dans les forces ou
qui ne sont plus auprès des citoyens et
pourtant l'été impose de commandement je
pense que ça doit attirer l'attention de
nos goûts
vernant moi j'attends de mes gouvernants
qui soit à la hauteur de la gouvernance
que nous travaillons pour eux ont parlé
des suicides de policiers il ya
également eu un policier est mort alors
oui on peut dire que j'ai changé deux
collègues qui ont mis fin à leur jour
une femme un homme et j'ai aussi à mes
collègues qui on vote entendent arrêter
un voleur qui est quand même le coeur de
notre métier s'est fait rouler dessus et
malheureusement elle est décédée et je
profite de votre chaîne pour adresser
toutes mes condoléances à sa famille
effectivement plusieurs centaines de
policiers ont observé une minute de
silence aujourd'hui en hommage à ce
collègue clairement vous vous sentez
soutenu aujourd'hui par la hiérarchie
dans ces épreuves
alors moi j'aimerais que notre ministère
d'emploi en l'occurrence comme les
dolium ce questionnaire soit le plus
proche des policiers qu'il n'ait pas
changé ton et qu'ils nous soutiennent
parce que nous sommes souvent très
souvent agresser on nous envoie en
première ligne pour régler des conflits
sociaux qui ne sont pas toujours de
notre fait qu'un évidemment aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas être toujours que la
réponse aux retraites au gilet jaune et
demain matin savez de quoi vous avez
justement l'impression que ces
manifestants vous amalgame vous au
gouvernement parfois abc le but en fait
franchement on nous mais on est vite
voir oui c'est le but je pense que
gouvernement nous met en exergue trois
en fait la seule réponse et nouvelles
des décollectes au modèle concon le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on met des
jeunes policiers qui sont pleins de
vigueur qui ça fait un travail mais on
les forme pas on n'a plus aucune
formation continue l'école des gardiens
de la paix c'était 12 mois après ces
passes et 11 ou un maton sept à neuf
mois
il faut une formation on peut pas donner
des armements à des policiers si on ne
les forme pas et si on ne les entraîne
pas vous allez me parler de la mort de
ceux de ce monsieur qui est décédé son
scooter la famille a reçu aujourd'hui
par christophe castaner qui est très
déçue la famille
finalement parce que ses agents n'ont
pas été suspendues alors monsieur
monsieur l'allemand qui n'est pas un
homme connu pour sa tendresse est rendu
au commissariat de police du 7ème
arrondissement
thibault de montbrial qui en charge
cette avocate qui est en charge de la
défense de mes collègues je les lui tout
à l'heure avant de venir me disais que
mes collègues et effondré mes collègues
ils sont dans une situation qui est
terrible parce que les gestes
d'intervention qu'ils ont utilisés pour
essayer de faire en sorte que cet
individu soit maîtrisé dans de bonnes
conditions aussi bien pour lui que pour
nous n'ont pas fonctionné pour nous
c'est un échec
nous sommes tous des pères et des mères
de famille quand on a une intervention
qui se déroulent leur ce style là on
reste pas insensible et on est effondré
mais christophe crépin ce genre de geste
justement est-ce qu'il faut encore les
avoir voilà ce que ça doit être encore
accepté entre guillemets par par an
voilà le code de jesper comment on
appelle ça mais procédure tout simple je
vais pas aller au devant de l'enquète de
l'inspection générale qui nous fait
jamais de cadeau ça faut que les gens
qui vous regardent le sache que
l'inspection générale ne fait pas de
cadeau à la police nationale
contrairement à ce qui pourrait penser
l'inspection générale et là ils ont un
cadre d' enquête ils font leurs cadres
dans quête ils vont déterminer d'un
point de vue administratif et la foi de
vue judiciaire quelles sont les
responsabilités de mes collègues mais
aujourd'hui mes collections dans un état
ici lisons ils ont provoqué parce qu'il
ya également une concomitance entre
leurs interventions et le décès de jours
après de ce pauvre livreurs et nous
mêmes nous présentons nos condoléances à
cette famille parce que c'est un échec
merci en tout cas christophe n'est venu
parler avec sincérité en tout cas sur le
plateau d'ayrté france reste avec nous
dans quelques instants notre débat sur
les revenants de neige libéré de prison
en france quel suivi pour ces anciens
détenus à l'intérieur et une fois remis
en liberté quelles mesures particulières
sont ils vraiment des repentis
peuvent-ils prétendre à une nouvelle vie
nous en débattrons avec nos invités
[Musique]
à quels types d'élèves s'adresse cette
nouvelle proposition éducative les
enfants que nous allons recevoir nous au
cours des frères montgolfier sont ceux
qui n'ont pas atteint le seuil qui leur
permet d'être reconnu
ces élèves sont des élèves finalement on
a soupçonné qui s'était dyspraxiques
dyslexique enfants intellectuellement
précoces nous travaillons et c'est là
notre réussite
non pas qu'ils aient un examen mais
qu'ils aient la capacité de revenir
d'une manière très confortable sur le
terrain classique tant qu'on n'aura pas
compris que nous avons nous sommes en
train de vivre un énorme tournant et un
énorme bouleversement de la pratique
d'être professeur aujourd'hui et demain
nous aurons un mal être
nous sommes en train de former les
adultes de demain il faut comprendre que
la france de nos banlieues et la france
et qu'il faut l'a formé et qui ne désire
que cela
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode de ses
caches consacré cette semaine à vos
prévisions olivier quand je fais des
scénarios je le souhaite pas forcément
on a toujours ce problème avec la chine
qui essaie de lutter contre l'hégémonie
américaine
assez paradoxalement je pense que la
chine est plus dangereux que l'iran je
pense qu'on est un pays qui est aux
abois savez quand les guerres se
déclenchent elles se déclenche toujours
parce que les gens ils y ont intérêt à
être 4e prévisions le break cité un
éclatement de la zone euro non moi je
crois pas du tout à un éclatement de la
zone euro et j'attends même avec une
certaine impatience l'entrée de l'ecosse
dans la zone euro alors je ne sais pas
si les causes va rétablir la frontière
est embêté la reine d'angleterre mais en
revanche l'union européenne va avoir
quelques soucis en 2020 mais c'est bien
dit la crise est derrière nous donc la
wii donc la crise de l'euro est derrière
nous donc le fmi je sais que pour
olivier si ça va faire vibrer
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
arte france merci de nous rejoindre
c'est le premier jihadiste français
condamné pour s'être rendu en syrie
ferait bien moreau 32 ans est sorti hier
de détention en novembre 2014 il avait
écopé de sept ans de détention pour
association de malfaiteurs en vue de la
préparation d'un acte de terrorisme
retour sur son itinéraire avec rania
berrada flavien moreau d'origine
sud-coréenne a été adopté par un couple
de nantais en 1988 il avait 15 mois
quand il est arrivé en france il s'est
converti à l'islam durant son
adolescence avant de se radicaliser en
prison où il était inculpé pour des
faits de petite délinquance en 2012
à sa sortie de détention flavien moreau
s'est rendu en syrie
il n'est resté qu'une dizaine de jours
durant lesquels il a appris à manier des
armes pour ce séjour il a écopé en
novembre 2014 de sept ans de prison pour
association de malfaiteurs en vue de la
préparation d'un acte de terrorisme
aujourd'hui lille où fabien moreau sera
particulièrement surveillé par les
services de renseignement français et
continuera d'être suivies par la justice
pendant plus de onze mois
selon les informations de france info il
devra se plier à plusieurs convocations
par le juge d'application des peines et
aux services d'insertion et de probation
de loire-atlantique
il s'agit donc du premier revenant aux
jihadistes français libéré de prison sur
le territoire c'était donc hier après
cette année je le disais d'incarcération
alors qu'une trentaine en plus d'une
trentaine même de libération sont
attendus cette année
quel traitement est il réservé à ces
détenus condamnés pour terrorisme
islamiste à leur sortie doit-on leur a
réservé un suivi particulier durant
l'incarcération mais aussi une fois
qu'ils se retrouvent dans l'espace
public c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir qu
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec nadia rayman la présidente
de la brigade des mers bonsoir 1 à diar
et maintenat merci d'être avec nous en
direct j'ai regardé france et puis en
direct par skype
nicolas moreau chroniqueur chez
atlantico merci à vous aussi d'être
présent avec nous à distance mais ça ne
va pas vous empêcher évidemment de
débattre avec nadia redman a ici
présentes sur les studios parisiens
tout d'abord première rentrée en manier
en matière dans le coeur de ce débat est
ce que selon vous ces prisonniers sont
qu'il des détenus comme les autres
nicolas moreau naucler mentale parce que
ce sont des détenus qui sont extrêmement
dangereux et qui ressorte en étant tout
aussi dangereux donc clairement ce sont
des sondés des comptes pour lesquels la
détention l'a absolument rien apporté et
ce sont des détenus qui sont connus pour
être radicaliser et pour la plupart qui
se sont radicalisés en prison donc
clairement une vos pass des radicaliser
en allant en prison dont il faut soit
inventer autre chose
soit les isoler de la société de manière
plus ferme et mais pour l'instant on ne
peut pas les traiter comme les autres
des couleurs nadia rain man a en gros
voilà ils seront jamais des détenus et
des ex détenus comme les autres qu'il
faut peut-être les isoler de la société
sans n'en débattra vrai vous êtes
d'accord avec le diagnostic de nicolas
moreau on a fait tout à fait d'accord et
puis après le problème pose pas je pense
qu'on est pas prêt de toute façon à les
rincer réintégrer dans la société de
toute façon c'est bien ils veulent pas
de toute façon sera intégré dans la
société et je pensais qu'ils ont
partiellement vides passe ailleurs pas
envie du tout de toute façon après bon
ils ont fait leurs prises sept ans de
prison on va nous dire bon de toute
façon ils ont purgé leur peine c'est
beau et ça mais moi ce qui me fait peur
ce le suivi parce que le suivi c'est le
suivi ce classique 1 il doit se rendre
je pense une fois par semaine et pointer
au commissariat surveillance judiciaire
et ça c'est le truc classique je parle
pour les petites peines à ces intrus
classique on a pas rajouté quelque chose
de plus pour dire effectivement alors on
avec al ahmad
on va pardonner mon inconscient
variations avec jubilation des soins pas
d'autorisation tout de même de
déplacement ils peuvent se déplacer pour
veiller on va pas mettre vous savez mais
je pense qu'effectivement on n'est pas
prêt de toute façon à accompagner ce
genre de 2,2 public j'allais dire de
terroristes on n'est pas plus près et
déjà effectivement déjà il était dans un
contexte pendant un temps où il s'est
encore plus radicalisés je pense que un
moment donné quand ces gens-là danser
après sept ans de prison
juste après il faut dit il faudrait
qu'il ya une institution je sais pas un
foyer où quelque chose qui soit encore
surveiller parce qu'on parle de
terrorisme nous parle pas quelqu'un qui
a volé un scooter mais moi
personnellement avec le travail de
terrain que je fais que je suis et j'ai
même moins travailler dans les prisons
oui autres auprès de ce public là je
peux vous dire que on n'est pas prêt on
n'est pas prêts du tout à recevoir ce
genre de public pascal et chelsea c'est
intéressant ce qu'on vous dit puisque
vous êtes au contact de ces personnes
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire ça
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que ces personnes
c'est djihadistes qui sont allés en
syrie vous dise clairement
alors moi ce que ce que ce qu'ils me
disent alors le dise effectivement pour
eux c'est toujours le même discours on
est dix victimes on n'a rien fait c'est
l'injustice on a été défendre des
pauvres malheureux ils ont tout le monde
à ce discours
voilà de l'utilisation entre guillemets
et après il ya l'idéologie qu'on le
veuille ou non elle est là faut pas
l'oublier ils sont convaincus que de
toute façon ils veulent de toute façon
islamiser la france qu'on le veuille ou
non de toute façon pour eux c'est pas
qu'un pour eux en fin de compte c'est
comme si qu'ils étaient des héros pour
une se voyait pas comme délinquants ou
hors la loi il se voyait comme des héros
et son ils sont en mission et leur
mission ne s'arrête pas une fois qu'ils
sont sortis de prison
alors ce que leur dit le juge ou ce
qu'on va leur mettre en place je pense
que qui s'en foutent chalaisien nicolas
moreau 70 personnes incarcérées pour
terrorisme dont la moitié est
effectivement de serre venant de syrie
quarante deux personnes libérable en
2020 ça vous
inspire quoi ces chiffres c'est sorte on
a un vrai problème puisque les mesures
de suivi sont absolument pas en est on
l'a vu au début de l'année avec
plusieurs plusieurs dates à la suite il
suffit d'une demi heure maintenant pour
faire un attentat l'ont prend plutôt on
va en bas de chez soi les quais en
attaque d innocence et pas en allant
pointer au commissariat même tous les
jours donc de s'en sortir il faudrait
voir beaucoup plus strict de dessins et
et là on est en train en fait de jeu par
principe par la tipp
on est en train de se créer un problème
qui va être insurmontable on a vu des
vertes et pour les policiers pour leur
enseignement puisque on n'a pas encore
fini par réveiller les revenants du
jihad
on n'a pas encore trouvé de solution
pour les djihadistes qui étaient
incarcérés dans le nord de la syrie et
on est déjà en train de se créer un
autre problème avec des djihadistes qui
sont pas du tour et radicalisée et pour
qui on met des mesures de suivi qui sont
absolument pas adapté au mode opératoire
terroriste actuelle donc commencé
effectivement très inquiétant et il ya
loin de rassurant à dire ont rassuré des
gens sur ce point effectivement va
libérer 40 personnes qui sont des des
tueurs potentiels qui sont des besoins
potentiels qui sont sans doute plus
radicalisme et maintenant qui alors
entré en prison et qui pour beaucoup
n'auront plus rien à perdre puisqu'ils
vont avoir des mesures très
contraignantes qui vous vivent comme des
lions aux cages dès qu'ils auront une
occasion de s'en sortir pour aller pour
aller mener une attaque un certain
nombre de fronts puisque de toute façon
plus rien à perdre et ces gens là ne se
rappelleront europe a pas de sitôt enfin
pas pour beaucoup
si je peux me permettre aussi déjà on a
des jeunes - qui travaillent dans les
quartiers tous à des jeunes qui n'ont
pas été en prison son papillon mais qui
pour moi sont radicalisés et qui sont
pas en prison mais qui pour moi ont un
discours de radicalisation de toute
façon alors effectivement en france on
punit l'acte
las cette personne là parce qu'elle a
été en syrie les temps
disons que ça voilà ce que c'est un
départ en séries mais il faut qu'on
comprenne il faut arrêter de se mentir
on a une grande majorité malheureusement
je dis bien une grande majorité qui ne
sont pas partis en syrie mais qui ont
guidé au logis et qui pensent exactement
comme cette personne qui vient de
quitter la prison et autres le problème
c'est ça c'est qu'on a une grande jones
qui est radicalisée et en face de nous
on a des gens qui sont en train de nous
dire maintenant les pauvres malheureux
vous êtes méchant avec eux vous êtes
islamophobe et l'on parle pas alors
panky aura pas un courage politique
moi j'invite ces politiques de venir
dans les quartiers et on a des jeunes
aujourd'hui l'heure seul le repère c'est
le coran le seul livre qu'il y ait
qu'ils apprécient c'est le courant et on
a des professionnels et bas qui savent
plus comment faire et on a aussi des
encadreurs des gens qu'ils encadrent ces
jeunes qui eux mêmes et pour cette
idéologie
alors aujourd'hui on n'est pas en face
de petits délinquants ou en phase de
d'échec scolaire
on est en face de gens qui et poussines
épousé une belgique et qu'ils sont
convaincus alors entre ceux qui vont
sortir les retours de série et ceux qui
sont dans notre territoire mais qui
n'ont pas eu tant leur étant en prison
mais qui sont radicalisés il n'y a pas
que déjà l'on parle des jeunes ya des
femmes et des familles entières et en
même temps aujourd'hui on a des
politiques qui défendent ce genre de
radicalisation après jeudi les landes la
radicalisation en tête mmm éradication
et qui justifient par excusez moi vous
avez raison qui justifie en disant oui
mais les pauvres regarder où est-ce
qu'ils habitent regarder ceux ci aux
repères identitaires on nous invente des
mots mais on doit déjà alors je pense si
on aime déjà nos citoyens on aime nos
jeunes gens il faut les protéger et pour
protéger je pense qu'il faut commencer
très très très très jeune il faut pas
faire de cadeaux je suis désolé il faut
que toute la société s'implique quand
j'ai dit toute la société je parle de
l'éducation nationale des éducateurs et
vous faire attention qui encadrent
d'abord ses jambes ses enfants c'est je
laisse sont pas radicaliser tout seuls
n'y a toujours eu un début alors nous
particulièrement à sevran on avait été
on avait dénoncé on les appelle les
rabatteurs moi personnellement je
avait alerté le préfet j'ai alerté le
maire à l'époque j'ai alerté tout le
monde les a dit on m'a dit que non
c'était rien c'était c'était eux des
gens qu'ils avaient le droit de
pratiquer tout ça alors moi je voudrais
revenir un petit peu en arrière moi je
suis d'origine berbère j'ai connu le
terrorisme en algérie
je connais je sais comment fonctionnent
ces gens là ils vont pas venir du jour
au lendemain sont très gentils ils ont
pris en plus des places comme le social
et tout ça ils ont commencé par prendre
la place le cari quartier et tout le
monde les aime bien effectivement et
après eux ils ont ils raison il sait pas
comment vous expliquez que c'est pas un
programme pour demain pour deux ans eux
ils ont le temps et se disent d'entrants
pendant 40 ans il vole réconquérir une
histoire de tout en haut et c'est ça
leur but ne sont pas pressés il y en a
cent qui meurent mais en a 300 qui sont
bien c'est comme en forme
vous allez peut-être retrouver dur c'est
comme si confort mais des soldats des
militaires c'est pas on va pas former
des citoyens
je voudrais vous faire écouter puisque
vous êtes d'un avis quasi identique un
contrepoids peut-être le juge
antiterroriste david le pas pour lui les
renseignements ont les moyens de suivre
les habitudes les individus à leur
sortie de prison
j'entends que l'on puisse avoir des
appréhensions mais comment se protéger
si on ne les a pas sous la main la
meilleure méthode c'est de les juger et
de les contrôler si dans 15 20 30 ans
ces personnes constituent encore une
menace en sortant de prison où est mené
un travail d'évaluation exemplaires ils
resteront sous le contrôle des services
de renseignement et de justice en
nicolas moreau ceux jugés assez
optimiste un lui il dit banon en france
on a les moyens on peut les contrôler et
vous vous disiez tout à l'heure
justement on n'a pas les moyens de ce
suivi
qu'est-ce que vous préconise auriez
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ces
gens une fois qu'ils ont purgé leur
peine
voilà la peine de mort n'existe pas en
france et c'est peut-être parce que vous
souhaitez non plus
voilà la peine de mort n'existe pas en
france ça n'existe indirectement quand
les djihadistes sont à l'étranger
et quand tu es quand on organise des
opérations des attaques contre notamment
sur des terrains de guerre mais sur le
terrain purement français il n'y a pas
de solution ce que ce juge déclare n'est
pas ce qui est appliqué les peines de 15
20 30 ans n'existent pas ce sont des
peines de 7 ans qui s'applique
actuellement même le frère de flavien
bourreau qui s'appelle nicolas moreau
qui était pas un profil à peu près
comparable au sien et ces deux parts de
la famille puisque vous avez beau mais
nicolas moreau précise heureusement que
j'ai un deuxième prénom craint lundi
pour le coup pour le coup non ils sont
c'est un profil beaucoup plus dures son
frère il s'appelle nicolas moreau il a
été il a été condamné à 10 ans de prion
dix ans en prison seulement donc il ya
pas de 15 20 30 ans avec suivi à 10 ans
de prison pour le suivre on a des
services de renseignements qui sont
complètement dépassés enfin j'aurai pen
qui l'attend à la préfecture au sein
même du renseignement de la préfecture
donc s'ils n'arrivent pas à suivre un de
leurs collègues qui est complètement
radicaliser je vois pas comment ils vont
suivre et le temps qui ne pensent qu'à
s'échapper et donc les solutions au
niveau macro elle sera évidemment de
refaire des budgets non de ce nom pour
la police et la justice parce que la
justice aille au budget d'à peine 9
milliards d'euros dont il n'y a pas
assez de prison passée de juge ces deux
de suivi et c'est la solution la plus
efficace qui serait très coûteuse et qui
serait la plus difficile en étant table
façon correcte
ce sera évidemment un guantanamo à la
française c'est à dire que vous avez un
centre spécial où on traite les
djihadistes et pour que ça se passe pas
dans les conditions déplorables du
guantanamo américain il faut énormément
de garde-fous et de et de petits détails
comme avec des délais de traitement des
dossiers qu'ils soient très raccourci
des recours possibles qu'ils soient
soient effectifs etc
et ça ça demande savoir d'une mise en
place qui coûte très cher heureusement
pour tout ce qui est régalien n'a pas de
budget on a tendance à dépenser beaucoup
plus dans des éoliennes ou des jeux
olympiques ou des trucs qui peine à
briller comme secondaire et ça fait 40
ans qu'on ne dote pas correctement alors
est gagnant donc
donc aujourd'hui on en paye le prix et
il nous reste des discours assez
rassurant tac les français s'inquiètent
mais je vois qu'en fait qui se juge va
rassurer quand il donne son discours et
puisqu'on annonce cinq minutes après
qu'une quarantaine de djihadistes tout
aussi dangereux qu'il a dit amoureux
vont être pour être libérés cette année
je vais vous faire écouter une solution
qui se rapproche peut-être d'ailleurs de
la vôtre c'était par des voix de la
droite aujourd'hui qui elle suggère des
centres de rétention écouté il faudrait
élargir la rétention de sûreté aux
djihadistes aux personnes condamnées
pour radicalisation pour acte de
terrorisme mais également à ceux qui
reviennent de ces théâtres de guerre
pour des détenus condamnés pour
terrorisme ou pour droit commun mais qui
ont été identifié comme islamiste
dangereux
on doit étudier au cas par cas des
mesures de rétention de sûreté
le français flavien moreau condamnés
pour terrorisme islamistes libérés ce 13
janvier 2019 après sept ans en prison
aucune action pour renforcer la
rétention de sûreté n'a été mise en
place par hollande macron pour protéger
les français malgré nos demandes
réitérées anaya redman à cette rétention
de sûreté est ce que c'est un fantasme
de la droite vous savez c'est aussi des
politiques la droite aussi a été au
pouvoir et la droite aussi a fait des
erreurs
bon effectivement en plein municipal
mois et puis moi j'ai travaillé dans les
villes de droite où effectivement on a
dénoncé tout ça je peux vous dire que la
droite quand on est là dans la ville et
dans les quartiers elle a complètement
un autre discours
c'est pas du tout les discours qu'ils
ont bien au contraire ils ont exactement
le même discours ils ont ils ont adhéré
aussi un moment donné moi je connais
très bien
j'ai travaillé dans les vignes comme lui
dit comme comme ils s'appellent le seul
à garder tout ça qu'on a alerté je peux
vous dire quand ils sont sur place ils
ont un autre discours quand ils sont
deux faces de ce public là pourquoi
raison c'est du clientélisme sinon c'est
la façon de jardiner au terrain c'est
quoi non c'est du clientélisme
effectivement c'est pour ça qu'on a
énormément de ce problème parce que
c'est par intérêt électoral parce qu'ils
pensent d'abord à eux d'abord et le
peuple après et malheureusement c'est
l'arroseur arrosé ils ont nourri le
monstre et la bête pardon et la bête est
devenu un monstre un moment donné on
pensait qu'il suffisait de faire une
mosquée il suffisait de faire un iftar
république un iftar c'est qu'en europe
le jeune pendant le ramadan il suffisait
de leur faire une petite boucherie par
ci une petite douche puis par là pour
que les mais c'est ça tout le monde a
participé alors la droite aujourd'hui
donnent des leçons mais faut pas oublier
qu'en 2005 comme quand monsieur sarkozy
était au pouvoir
la première des choses qu'il a retiré la
police de proximité et il nous a mis la
politique des grands frères alors je
voudrais dire à la droite je pense que l
a été au pouvoir et qu elle a échoué
aussi comme la gauche c'était un échec
cuisant pour vous la politique des
grands faire ça pouvait être sur le oui
oui parce qu'effectivement et ça
continue parce que mais malheureusement
à la politique des grands frères déjà
c'était les frères restés les hommes les
femmes s était exclu et la politique des
grands frères s'étaient qui au début des
grands frères c'était le petit caïd de
quartier qui vous dit qu'il devait
calmer entre guillemets les moins les
petits effectivement après leurs amis
des comptes rend leur a donné des
responsabilités après ce sont politisés
et puis après on a négocié avec eux et
puis les la politique des grands frères
c'était le discours de victimisation
c'était pas un discours de haut
républicain comme on dit aujourd'hui on
a peur de dire certaines choses
pourquoi pour nous parce que bon c'est
nous qui sommes traiter d'islamophobe et
j'en passe et j'en
passe aujourd'hui je pense qu'il manque
un courage politique et jamais lire
aussi on a un courage aussi de certains
journalistes
oui je pense aussi parce qu'elle est à
venir justement il manque aussi un
courage de certains journalistes qui il
suffit d'aller dans le terrain et puis
et puis après la justice effectivement l
essai assez clément pour certains choses
et est plus sévère je trouve pour des
choses vraiment pour elle a par exemple
pour la liberté d'expression condamner
quelqu'un pour la liberté d'expression
et essayer parce que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui à l'opinion publique et
les réseaux sociaux s'est dévoué on a
peur de l'opinion publique
malheureusement on oublie qu'il ya eu il
ya eu charlie et les attentats il ya eu
un prête quand même qui est mort dont on
a égorgé un prêtre dans l'église
imaginer le contraire qu'on aurait
égorgé un immeuble dans une mosquée vous
vous rendez compte
comme on en rirait agit pour moi un mort
où justement on a dit on a fait
référence à l'opinion publique j'allais
y venir parce que il ya celle peut-être
qu'ils jugent qui est entre guillemets
bien pensante peut-être mais il ya aussi
celle qui n'a pas du tout envie de voir
ces personnes revenir d'irak et jeu sauf
erreur elles sont absolument majoritaire
dans notre pays un des récents sondages
montrent que les français n'ont pas
envie que ces djihadistes reviennent sur
le sol est ce que c'est de là que
viendra peut-être la solution puisque
nadia nous expliquer clairement de
courage politique est-ce que ça va venir
des citoyens qui vont prendre conscience
de ce danger de ce problème selon vous
ça sera le mouvante un moment non parce
que maintenant
en fait depuis 2015 on a beaucoup
progressé sur le sur le l'islamisme sur
le terrorisme sur les méthodes sur les
méthodes des frères musulmans sur les
méthodes de salafistes sur sur l'
infiltration terroriste sur la
radicalisation a beaucoup progressé et
je pense qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup de
connaissances au niveau des français sur
tous ces sujets malheureusement on en
est arrivé dans une phase où la réalité
tellement effrayante que l'écrasante
majorité des français essaye de ne pas
la voir
c'est à dire qu'ils se cachent les yeux
il se bouche les oreilles il se tait il
essaye de faire sa vie comme si tout ça
n'existait pas et donc il n'y a pas
vraiment de pression populaire sur ces
sujets quelques sondages vous nous
servez là un petit peu c'est oublier au
bout de 2
et les français essaye vraiment de faire
leur vie de manière à aller au travail
ne devrait pas à payer leurs emprunts à
assurer l'éducation de leurs enfants
mais essaye à tout prix d'oublier au
maximum que charlie a eu lieu d'oublier
au maximum que tous ces attentats n'ont
au mieux et en conséquence en fait on
n'avance pas du tout on en revient
aujourd'hui cinq ans après charlie au
discours qu'il y avait en 2014
c'est-à-dire de dire que finalement il a
un petit peu cherché que il avait quand
même provoqué avec leurs caricatures et
puis dans le contexte actuel comme ça a
été bien soulignée par mes valeurs
humanistes et qu'elle sait que les
élections qui sont les pires du poil du
clientélisme qui sont les élections
locales municipales par arrive dans
trois mois donc là tout le monde marche
sur des oeufs puisque la dernière fois
aux élections et pas mal de villes de
l'ancienne banlieues rouges qui sont
tombées aux mains de la droite de lui
dire parce que la droite et le pays
avait misé sur un clientélisme vis-à-vis
de l'électorat musulman et effectivement
il ya eu ces fameuses politique des
grands frères dont on avait parlé des
constructions de mosquées et cetera des
promesses à la communauté musulmane en
considérant qu'ils ont connu des milieux
mais puisque ça a marché la dernière
fois notamment dans la banlieue rouge
parisienne et le monde de ce mois a été
a été relevée puisque sa manche et la
mer du nord est donc là on est dans une
période où il ya absolument aucun risque
qui est pris sur ce sujet aucun courage
politique tout ce qui est fait c'est
vraiment de deux de miser sur le mac
musulmans et d'essayer de gagner ces
villes qui sont des villes qui peuvent
basculer contrairement à d'autres
bastions qui sont qui sont plus
installés
ça sera le mot de la fin en tout cas
merci à vous n'aviez maintenant nicolas
moreau à distance d'avoir été avec nous
pour débattre parler de ce sujet merci à
vous deux merci
alors pour conférence internationale sur
la libye aura lieu dimanche le cessez le
feu reste en vigueur pour une durée
indéterminée informations des autorités
russes qui ont organisé une réunion avec
les deux rivaux libyen hier
sachez que le chef du gouvernement ont
reconnu par l'onu fayez al azhar h a
officiellement signé cet accord de
cessez-le-feu
kelly phare à l'ifa haftar lui a demandé
plus de temps pour y réfléchir
grazailles à avec florian lambert alors
qu'un accord de cessez le feu en libye
étaient en passe d'être signé khalifa
haftar a finalement quitté moscou ce
matin sans pas rater le moindre document
l'homme fort de l'est libyen avait
pourtant demandé un délai de réflexion
la veille son rival faille azal sa rage
avait formellement adopté ce cessez le
feu entré en vigueur dimanche
aux manettes pour tenter de régler un
conflit en cours depuis 2011
moscou et ankara leurs ministres des
affaires étrangères respectivement
sergueï lavrov et mevlüt cavusoglu ont
affirmé l'importance de cet accord lors
de leur rencontre à moscou
nous veillerons à ce que al sarah âgée
haftar assument toutes les obligations
nécessaires que le cessez-le-feu se
poursuivent et que nous entamions le
processus politique et qu'il se
poursuivent dans le cadre des efforts de
la communauté internationale et des
nations unies
la partie russe travaillera avec mu dans
les mêmes temps en turquie recep tayyip
erdogan rencontrait le président du
conseil des ministres guiseppe compter
tous deux ont insisté sur la nécessité
d'agir pour un accord durable qui
n'hésiteront jamais à infliger aux
putschistes haftar la leçon qu'il mérite
il poursuit ses attaques contre la
démonstration légitime et contre nos
frères en ligue 1 les discussions qui
souligne l'influencé croissante de la
diplomatie conjointe russo turques alors
qu'une apparente rivalité semblait se
profiler sur le terrain si fayaz elle sa
rage était soutenu par ankara qui
déploie ses militaires en renfort en
libye moscou serait écoutée de khalifa
haftar l'homme de l'est du pays mais les
deux partis alliés dans la négociation
ne renonce pas sergueï lavrov a ainsi
annoncé qu'il poursuivrait ses efforts
en vue d'une trêve
ou si nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
dans ce domaine pour le moment le
résultat définitif n'a pas été atteint
une initiative soutenue par angela
merkel al'approche de la conférence
internationale sur la libye qui se
tiendra à berlin ce dimanche sous
l'égide des nations unies
c'est la fin cette émission se retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour 1 point
complexe sur l'actualité
[Musique]
vous
votre lecture de juristes sur le système
japonais je peux dire que le système
judiciaire japonais est inique que dit
carlos ghosn hier dans sa conférence de
presse il explique qu'en réalité ses
avocats le japonais bien sûr ne pouvait
pas lui garantir un procès équitable
c'est dit est ce que cette affaire là
son évasion ne rend pas service quelque
part au japon
franchement le j'y crois pas trop parce
qu'il ya quand même l'effet négatif
c'est à dire je dirais l'humiliation
mais quelque part le départ de carlos
ghosn
indiscutablement leur rend service parce
que cette hypothèque sur l'honneur d'une
justice consistant à ce qu'un procès
soit en réalité l'expression d'une
décision politique
quel déshonneur qu'est ce qui pousse
tout simplement un apnéiste à vouloir
touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles le podium m6
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain environnement et c'est un
univers qui me permet justement d'aller
encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent plus on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
et a confiance et la capacité à vivre
l'instant présent à être connectés que
sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur le
toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de l'apnée
comment
c'est de notre pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
ce
[Musique]
les news ne s'arrête jamais
laissez votre soutien que nous
apprécions le plus
on
[Musique]
et parfois dramatique bordel tu as rien
à faire ici avec ton chariot
[Musique]
les arabes
m
[Musique]
la passion à ses les chiens nordiques
j'irai donc le chien de race husky de
sibérie qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens un meilleur
présente plein de choses parce que c'est
de l'amour de l'amour au quotidien je
tiens c'est pas une motoneige assez
bonne machine c'est pour nous faire
plaisir bien souvent qui courent chaque
chien à son caractère il ya certaines de
mes chiennes avec lequel earl wayne par
le regard on arrive à se comprendre
cette année on a fait un parcours à
l'envers arrivé à un moment depuis des
années enfin à gauche
cette année elle nous a fait prendre la
piste par la droite comment alors la
chienne de tête à s'est retourné et m'a
dit tu es sur ton coup parce que c'est
pas par là qu'il faut aller c'est
d'autre côté
[Musique]
emmanuel macron promet de continuer à
expliquer et concertée sur le projet de
réforme des retraites des propos qui
interviennent alors qu'une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation s'est déroulée
aujourd'hui à paris mais aussi à lille
certains syndicalistes se sont retrouvés
à une blessure seulement
du centre des déchets de la ville des
heurts ont éclaté avec les forces de
l'ordre
paris londres et berlin déclenché une
procédure visant à contraindre téhéran à
se plier à ses engagements nucléaires
contenues dans l'accord de vienne de
dans la foulée lire on les met en garde
contre les conséquences soient d'une
telle décision qui selon moscou
pour répondre à une nouvelle escalade la
conférence internationale sur la libye y
aura lieu ce dimanche à berlin hier la
réunion organisée par la russie avec les
deux rivaux libyen a permis des progrès
selon moscou alors que diplomatiquement
les efforts sur huit est plus pour
trouver une issue rapide
le président turc erdogan permet
d'infliger
hanifa tard il reprenait ses attaques
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct sur rt france après 41 jours
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites le gouvernement se tourne vers
le compromis en déplacement à pau
emmanuel macron a réagi en souhaitant
l'apaisement une directive suivi par le
gouvernement et le groupe la république
en marche et pourtant la mobilisation ne
semble pas faiblir les précisions de
florian lambert après 41 jours de
mobilisation le gouvernement souhaite
apaiser se tourner vers le compromis
trois jours après l'offre d'edouard
philippe de retirer sous condition lâche
pivot du projet c'est emmanuel macron
lui même qui a pris la parole ce mardi à
pau comme pour apaiser les tensions
qu'il faut avec beaucoup de calme
maintenant de clarté que notre pays
rentre dans cet état d'esprit payer
quand on quand on prend la peine
d'expliquer calmement et d'écouté on
peut lever beaucoup d'ambiguïtés
malentendu on ne lèvera pas le
mécontentement pour le premier ministre
edouard philippe la conférence de
financement permettra de résoudre le
conflit
je pense que la conférence de
financement réunissant les partenaires
sociaux proposera à la fin de ses
travaux une mesures d'âge afin
d'équilibrer le système des retraites
même son de cloche du côté du
gouvernement et du groupe la république
en marche
tous les éléments sont en place pour que
cette vielle se termine et notamment le
fait qu'aucun grévistes ne peut
aujourd'hui se sentir humilié par la
manière dont se conclut ce conflit
le jusqu'au boutisme n'est pas une
solution la réforme des retraites portée
par le gouvernement va garantir un
régime de retraite par répartition plus
juste et permettre à des milliers de
français d'avoir une retraite minimum à
1000 euros
et pourtant la mobilisation ne semble
pas faiblir plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont défilé mardi à paris en
répondant à l'appel des syndicats cgt fo
solidaires et fsu et dans le cortège le
compromis ne semble pas être le mot
d'ordre la réforme est venu au bon point
pour remobiliser les gens au final parce
que les gens se rendent compte comment
ça se passe vraiment dans les
manifestations et le peu de réponses que
nous apporte quand on manifeste pour
quelque chose sur laquelle on n'est pas
d'accord
même les grévistes qui avaient pas
encore participé au gilet jaune et qui
avait l'habitude de manifester avant se
rendre compte de tout ce qui est en
train de passer ce gouvernement veut
passer le maximum de réformes et a pu
avoir besoin de revenir là dessus
donc c'est très dangereux jean luc
mélenchon a annoncé mardi qu'il
proposait le dépôt d'une motion de
censure contre le gouvernement
le chef de file des députés insoumis
veut s'allier avec les députés du parti
communiste et le groupe des socialistes
pour mener à bien l'opération
nous allons proposer au groupe
communistes et socialistes de déposer
une motion de censure contre son
gouvernement
quel est le sens de voter sur un texte à
trous qui n'est pas complet le
gouvernement doit être mis au pied de
ses responsabilités sur la réforme des
retraites
à dix jours de la présentation du projet
de loi en conseil des ministres la
tension qui accompagne la réforme des
retraites permet difficilement
d'envisager la voie du compromis
six français sur dix soutiennent
toujours les manifestations et grève
contre les retraites selon le baromètre
harris interactive pour rtl et avait
faim faut un peu plus d'un tiers semble
de l'inquiétude élargissement des
critères de pénibilité une retraite
tranquille mille euros sont massivement
plébiscité
concernant le projet présenté 27% des
sondés souhaitent qu'il soit purement
annulé quand plus d'un sondé sur deux
est opposé à l âge pivot de 64 ans et
pour sébastien chenu porte parole du
rassemblement national député du nord il
existe des alternatives du système de
points qu emmanuel macron refuge de
mettre en place
nous avons considéré mais pas seulement
nous un certain nombre d'économistes y
compris d'ailleurs l'ancien ministre du
budget
de françois hollande qu'il y avait
aujourd'hui les capacités à pérenniser
ce système des retraites capacité
financière le déficit du système de
retraites est tout à fait capable d'être
compensée par un certain nombre de
réserves de fonds de réserve qui existe
actuellement
et puis surtout une autre politique à
mener si on veut sauvegarder notre
système de retraite dans le présent dans
le public il ne souhaite pas sauvegarder
notre système de retraite il souhaite le
déconstruire on est vers une retraite à
points à partir du moment où on veut
sauvegarder le système de retraite
on va vers une politique du patriotisme
économique de la réindustrialisation du
pays
on va aussi vers une politique de la
natalité encourager les français à faire
plus d'enfants pour que demain
évidemment il y ait plus d'actifs pour
payer les retraites de ceux qui partent
en retraite
ces deux levier natalité et patriotisme
économique
emmanuel macron ne les utilise pas parce
que ce n'est pas son objectif que de
pérenniser notre système de retraite
oui bien sûr qui a la possibilité de
pérenniser ce système de retraites mais
les blocages se multiplient un peu
partout en france c'est le cas devant
l'incinérateur d'ivry sur seine en
région parisienne action menée
aujourd'hui par la cgt un blocage
auxquelles les forces de l'ordre ont
tenté de s'interposer tôt ce matin les
grilles d'entrée ont été soudés afin
d'interdire l'accès à l'incinérateur
notre reporter david khalifa était sur
place
un chiffre à vous donner concernant le
traitement de déchets à paris trois
mille tonnes de déchets sont traités à
chaque jour dans la capitale française
un peu plus de 2000 sont traités ici
même une
un blocage qui peut avoir de lourdes
conséquences sur l'accumulation de
déchets qui peut y avoir à à paris cet
objectif est clair en tout cas pour
plusieurs de ces syndicats rester un
maximum de jours ici pour se faire
entendre du gouvernement et pour faire
retirer ce projet de loi de réforme de
retraite 517 c'est le nombre d'emplois
supprimés par auchan la direction estime
que le groupe doit d'adapter son
organisation et ses méthodes de travail
alors que son modèle s'essoufflent un
plan de départs volontaires dénoncé par
les syndicats les explications françois
tisci et beach
transformer son modèle afin d'être plus
à l'écouté des nouveaux besoins et
attentes du marché c'est avec ces
arguments que le directeur général
d'auchan retail a annoncé la suppression
nette de 510 7 emplois au siège du
groupe via un plan de départs
volontaires
aujourd'hui quand vous développez des
surfaces de beaucoup plus petite taille
qui sont parfois digitale et physique
comme le drive piéto vous pouvez changer
de jaillir d'offres produits d'une rue à
l'autre
donc il nous faut beaucoup plus
d'agilité il nous faut des profils
nouveaux et donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
nous allons intégrer de nouvelles
expertises en même temps que proposait
ce plan de départs volontaires pour 517
personnes
objectif selon la direction un retour à
l'équilibré financier un changement
profond à horizon 2022 avec pour
ambition de réaliser plus d'un milliard
d'euros d'économies de coûts
les syndicats eux demandent des
éclaircissements c'est beaucoup par
rapport à l'ensemble des trois
périmètres concernés
si on fait une règle de trois ne serait
ce que sur notre activité france on est
à plus de 15% de l'effectif concerné
donc c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup et ça demande beaucoup
d'éclaircissements parce que ça va des
structures est complètement certaines
activités en grande difficulté le groupe
de distribution avait déjà au printemps
dernier lancer un premier volet de son
plan de redressement
21 site auchan avait été mis en vente
employant au total plus de 700 salariés
en juillet dernier la direction avait
finalement déclaré avoir trouvé des
repreneurs pour 10 des sites en question
et cette contestation contre la réforme
des retraites a malheureusement été le
théâtre de violences policières
et même là qu'on s'est exprimé sur le
sujet le président demande des
propositions pour améliorer la
déontologie des policiers et des
gendarmes souhaitant que la justice
puisse continuer à travailler sur ces
cas il met en garde contre les amalgames
et insiste sur les violences dont je
souhaite les forces de sécurité
intérieures sont les premières victimes
et cette victime justement mortes à la
suite d'un projet initié une information
judiciaire a été ouverte pour homicide
involontaire famille et avocat de cédric
souvient parle d'une bavure ils ont
d'ailleurs été reçu aujourd'hui par
christophe castaner cédric joue via est
décédé le 3 janvier dernier après son
interpellation par des policiers à paris
a été victime d'une asphyxie avec une
fracture du larynx après avoir été
plaqué au sol casque sur la tête
écoutez la réaction déçu de l'un de ses
fils à la sortie de cet entretien il a
répondu à certaines de nos questions
mais bon on a quand même on est quand
même sorti en manque de quelque chose en
manque de
manque d'information voilà les policiers
nous notre principale question c était
que qu'est ce que font les quatre
policiers qui ont interpellé au mon père
et il n'a pas été en mesure de nous
répondre
s'il ya s'il était toujours en le
service si il pouvait encore contrôler
les gens alors que airlines et que tant
qu'il n'aurait pas une information qui
dirait que l'interpellation et quels
amendements père être provoquée par un
de leurs ges
il ne pourrait pas les suspendre alors
que voilà ça fait ça à faire presque
deux semaines que c'est dit clairement
dans tous les journaux dans tous les
articles que mon père a été tué par une
fracture du larynx
donc il ya fait qui a provoqué une
asphyxie
donc après si ça ce n'est pas une preuve
qui montrent que les policiers ont
ont provoqué des actes envers mon père
déloyale et avec grande brutalité
je sais pas si on peut dire de plus près
c'est dans ce contexte qu'une autre
affaire de violence policière a été
classée sans suite par le parquet de
paris la semaine dernière le gilet jaune
l'âge et les jaunes mélanie damien
victime d'un coup de matraque dans la
nuque réagi au micro d'rtl france le 20
avril 2019 léger les jeunes défilent à
paris lors d'une manifestation autorisée
mélanie une militante occupée à lire un
tract ne voit pas la charge de crs
derrière son dos elle est alors
violemment frappé par surprise par un
crs et elle s'effondre elle nous raconte
je suis seul où j'ai les bras levés j'ai
le papier dans la main un homme
fait 28 pas donc cours sur 30 mètres
arme son bras et massène un coup de
matraque dans la nuque ces images
signalé par le journaliste et écrivain
david dufresne provoque l'indignation
sur les réseaux sociaux
elles vont être visionnée plus d'un
million de fois mélanie travailleuse
sociale et porte-parole des gilet jaune
damien les réfractaires du 80 se
souvient je perd connaissance à
plusieurs reprises je dirais 3 à 4 fois
que je me souviens de la douleur et je
me souviens d'après la douleur j'ai eu
une entorse des cervicales et les
disques c4 et c5 qui sont morts ou la
légiste m'a dit que si jamais je n'avais
pas eu cette écharpe je serai étape
tétraplégique à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
pour moi c'était même pas envisageable
que ce soit un homme qui ait fait ça
délibèrement je ne pouvais pas
l'imaginer parce que moi j'ai grandi
dans une famille où on nous a donné des
valeurs de respect qu'un uniforme ça se
respecte et cette mère de famille porte
plainte contre x
mais surprise début janvier le parquet
de paris classe la plainte sans suite
selon la justice le choix du policier
dollar poussée lors de sa charge était
justifiée même si la blessure subie
n'était pas recherché
il a en outre jugé que la vitesse de
marche de la gilet jaune
allez la laisser derrière le nouveau
barrage qu'ils essayaient d'établir ce
qui était dangereux
cette décision a révolté plusieurs
personnalités et bien entendu mélanie
dans mon éducation deux quartiers
populaires c'est ce qu'on m'a appris ce
que mon père m'a transmis qui ne court
pas tu n'as rien fait mélanie tu ne
cours pas il ya que les délinquants qui
courent et que ceux qui ont quelque
chose à se reprocher qui courent moi je
cours je la mets sait jamais rien à me
reprocher en fait mais il ya un recours
on va aller jusqu'au bout on va les
saigner les recours tout ce qu'on va
pouvoir faire on le fera
mon but c'est pas de gagner de l'argent
c'est juste que quand une personne ne
tape le nom de mon agresseur dans google
y est pas toutes ses médailles parce
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui ce monsieur a
été même médaillé au mois de mai mélanie
affirme connaître l'identité du crs en
question le milieu militant crois qu'il
s'agit d'un homme déjà connu pour des
faits similaires et la important que la
police est une vraie police pour les
juger aujourd'hui
un policier qui lance un pavé qui ne
touche personne prend trois mois avec
sursis comme excuse s'il fallait
condamner quelqu'un c'était une personne
qui avait blessé un manifestant un
militant cette militante n'est pas
découragé de manifester et continuer à
fédérer les gilet jaune d'amiens
pour elle il est nécessaire de ne pas
plier devant la peur au nom du combat
pour la justice sociale et pour
christophe crépin porte parole du
syndicat france police christophe
castaner ne doit pas oublier que la
police et la gendarmerie vivent une
période difficile nous sommes la
profession la plus contrôlée que ce soit
il la police ou la gendarmerie on est
contrôlé à tous les niveaux nous avons
l'inspection générale de la police
nous avons le parquet nous avons le
défenseur des droits systématiquement
dès qu'on a une vidéo
la hiérarchie nous convoque et nous non
des explications on n'a pas attendu
d'avoir ce genre de déclaration qui est
pour moi une déclaration politique et
qui ne va pas certainement pas aller
dans le sens de mes collègues et moi
j'ai le plus profond respect des
institutions mon pays du président de la
république de monsieur castaner
néanmoins il faut pas qu'ils oublient
que la police nationale et la
gendarmerie nous traversons une période
qui est sans précédent et qui est une
période très difficile nous avons attiré
son attention par des intersyndicales
qui n'ont pas été suivies d'effet
même sur les retraites nous sommes pas
aligner police gendarmerie
nous allons nous sommes dans un désarroi
total
vous avez aussi iraniens présents la
france l'allemagne et le royaume uni
tentent de contraindre l'iran ils ont
déclenché les procédures leur permettant
de forcer téhéran à respecter ses
engagements sur le nucléaire des
explications de valentin carpentier
si les états unis veulent de plus en
plus de sanctions l'europe menace ait
choisi la voie de la contrainte
les trois pays européens cosignataire de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien sont
montés au créneau pour mettre la
pression sur l'iran pour y parvenir la
france l'allemagne et le royaume uni ont
déclenché le mécanisme de règlement des
différends prévu dans le texte afin
d'obliger téhéran à respecter ses
engagements
nous n'avons plus d'autre choix étant
donné les mesures prises par l'iran que
de faire part aujourd'hui de nos
préoccupations quant au fait que l'iran
ne respecte pas ses engagements au titre
du gie cypihot et et de saisir la
commission conjointe dans le cadre du
mécanisme de règlement des différends
conformément aux dispositions du
paragraphe 36 ipo et ce faisant nos
trois pays ne rejoignent pas la campagne
visant à exercer une pression maximale
contre l'iran nous agissons en toute
bonne foi avec l'objectif primordial de
préserver l'accord et dans l'espoir
sincère de trouver une solution pour
sortir de l'impasse
par le biais d'un dialogue diplomatique
constructif tout en restant dans son
cadre nous espérons ramener l'iran au
plein respect de ses engagements au
titre du g6 pihouet annoncé depuis
plusieurs semaines par paris
le mécanisme de règlement des différends
a finalement été lancée et pourrait
mener à terme au rétablissement des
sanctions de l'onu
levée après 2015 l'europe c'est pourtant
prononcé contre des sanctions et
souhaite sauver la corde 2015 dans un
mais cela va à l'encontre de la volonté
de donald trump qui a demandé aux
européens de se retirer
boris johnson s'est quant à lui dit
favorable au remplacement de l'accord de
vienne par un texte proposé par le
président américain le chef de la
diplomatie européenne mme josette borel
a tenu à réaffirmer qu'aucune sanction
ne seraient émises envers l'iran
l'objectif du mécanisme de règlement des
différends n'est pas de ré imposer des
sanctions
ce mec il propose que ce mécanisme vise
à résoudre les problèmes liés à la mise
en oeuvre de l'accord dans le cas de la
commission mixte je pense qu'il doit
être clair que l'objectif est donc de
trouver des solutions et de revenir au
plein respect dans le cadre de cet
accord le mécanisme de règlement des
différends exige un effort intensif de
bonne foi de tous les membres en tant
que coordinateur je m'attends à ce que
tous les participants processus la mort
dans cet état d'esprit que nous devons
préserver l'accord sur le nucléaire tu
peux travailler pour revenir à une mise
en oeuvre complète efficace tôt faut un
effectif complet
de son côté l'iran a répondu et a mis en
garde berlin londres et paris contre les
conséquences de cette décision et cette
déclaration ce matin du président
iranien l'iran doit punir tous les
responsables de la catastrophe aérienne
du boeing l'ukrainien justice iranienne
a par ailleurs annoncé à plusieurs
arrestations
rappel soit 176 passagers et membres
d'équipage ont perdu la vie mercredi
dernier après qu'un avion d'une
compagnie ukrainienne a été abattu par
erreur par un missile iranien
samedi les forces armées iraniennes ont
reconnu leur responsabilité le soir même
une cérémonie d'hommage aux victimes à
virey la manifestation contre les
autorités aux cris de mort aux menteurs
cet incident était sans précédent dans
l'histoire de notre pays
il n'y a jamais eu un moment où un
responsable de nos systèmes de défense
aérienne où un officier a commis une
telle erreur contre un avion de
passagers dans la capitale du pays
au centre du pays et près de l'aéroport
international tout en me rapprochant des
familles qui ont été frappés par cette
grande tragédie
je leur dis que nous continuerons sur
cette voie
jusqu'à découvrir tous les aspects de
l'incident et punir les personnes
impliquées et enfin rassurer les gens
qu'un tel incident ne se reproduira plus
une conférence internationale sur la
libye aura lieu dimanche le cessez le
feu reste en vigueur pour une durée
indéterminée informations des autorités
russes qui ont organisé une réunion avec
les deux rivaux libye derrière et sachez
que le gouffre le chef du gouvernement
ont reconnu par l'onu alassane a
officiellement signé cet accord de
cessez-le-feu khalifa haftar lui ai
demandé plus de temps pour la réflexion
grazailles avec florian lambert alors
qu'un accord de cessez le feu en libye
étaient en passe d'être signé
khalifa haftar a finalement quitté
moscou ce matin sans pas rater le
moindre document l'homme fort de l'est
libyen avait pourtant demandé un délai
de réflexion
la veille son rival fayez al sarah
jamais formellement adopté ce cessez le
feu entré en vigueur dimanche
aux manettes pour tenter de régler un
conflit en cours depuis 2011
moscou et ankara leurs ministres des
affaires étrangères respectivement
sergueï lavrov et mevlüt cavusoglu ont
affirmé l'importance de cet accord lors
de leur rencontre à moscou
nous veillerons à ce que al zahar alger
haftar assument toutes les obligations
nécessaires que le cessez-le-feu se
poursuivent et que nous entamions le
processus politique et qu'il se
poursuivent dans le cadre des efforts de
la communauté internationale et des
nations unies
la partie russe travaillera avec moi
dans le même temps turquie recep tayyip
erdogan rencontrait le président du
conseil des ministres guiseppe compter
tous deux ont insisté sur la nécessité
d'agir pour un accord durable mais
n'hésiteront jamais à infliger aux
putschistes haftar la leçon qu'il mérite
il poursuit ses attaques contre
l'administration légitime et contre nos
frères en limite des discussions qui
souligne la science croissante de la
diplomatie conjointe russo turques alors
qu'une apparente rivalité semblait se
profiler sur le terrain si fayez al
chaar âge était soutenu par ankara qui
déploie ses militaires en renfort en
libye moscou serait écoutée de khalifa
haftar l'homme de l'est du pays mais les
deux partis alliés dans la négociation
ne renonce pas sergueï lavrov a ainsi
annoncé qu'il poursuivrait ses efforts
en vue d'une trêve
ou si nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
dans ce domaine pour le moment le
résultat définitif n'a pas été atteint
une initiative soutenue par angela
merkel al'approche de la conférence
internationale sur la libye qui se
tiendra à berlin ce dimanche sous
l'égide des nations unies
et pour séduire morel quand tu es
journaliste spécialiste de l'afrique le
grand absent de la gestion diplomatique
de la crise libyenne ce sont les
africains coûté tous ces pays au sud du
sahara sont tributaires des dégâts
collatéraux de la déliquescence de la db
à le terrorisme qui sont nourris et on
nous a mis en même temps comme
commission de
un duo niveau pour la gestion de la
crise en libye comme africains denis
sassou nguesso qui lui-même du congo
brazzaville qui est lui-même un qui
lui-même terrorise son peuple donc
pourquoi il n'apparaît pas dans ce
dossier pourquoi l'afrique me ne paraît
pas dans la gestion de cette crise là on
aimerait bien avoir de plus amples
explications
est-ce que c'est dû à l'attitude part
qu'on qualifie de non-démocratique de sa
soutien emprisonne et là à noël vient de
faire quatre prisonniers supplémentaires
est ce qu'on ne veut pas en rajouter a
déjà ce qui est trés brouillées dans
cette gestion il ya autant de questions
que nous nous posons et nous aimerions
savoir pourquoi l'afrique n'est pas elle
n'est pas présente
c'est le premier jihadiste français
condamné pour s'être rendu en syrie
flavien moreau 32 ans est sorti hier de
détention en novembre 2014 il avait
écopé de sept ans de détention pour
association de malfaiteurs en vue de la
préparation d'un acte de terrorisme
retour sur son itinéraire avec rania
berrada flavien moreau d'origine
sud-coréenne a été adopté par un couple
de nantais en 1988 il avait 15 mois
quand il est arrivé en france il s'est
converti à l'islam durant son
adolescence avant de se radicaliser en
prison où il était inculpé pour des
faits de petite délinquance en 2012 à sa
sortie de détention
flavien moreau s'est rendu en syrie il
n'est resté qu'une dizaine de jours
durant lesquels il a appris à manier des
armes pour ce séjour il a écopé en
novembre 2014 de sept ans de prison pour
association de malfaiteurs en vue de la
préparation d'un acte de terrorisme
aujourd'hui libre flavien moreau sera
particulièrement surveillé par les
services de renseignement français et
continuera d'être suivies par la justice
pendant plus de onze mois
selon les informations de france info il
devra se plier à plusieurs convocations
par le juge d'application des peines et
aux services d'insertion et de probation
de loire-atlantique
1 quelle mesure pour les djihadistes qui
sortent de prison vous propose d'écouter
les analyses de nadia ray maintenant
président de la brigade des mers et de
nicolas moreau chroniqueur chez
atlantico on n'est pas prêt de toute
façon à accompagner ce genre de 2,2
public j'allais dire de terroristes on
n'est pas plus près et déjà
effectivement déjà il était dans un
contexte pendant sept ans où il s'est
encore plus radicalisés je pense que un
moment donné quand ces gens-là danser
après sept ans de prison
juste après il faut dit il faudrait qu'à
une institution je sais pas un foyer où
quelque chose qui soit encore surveiller
parce qu'on parle de terrorisme nous
parle pas quelqu'un qui a volé un
scooter mais moi personnellement avec le
travail de terrain que je fais que je
suis et j'ai même moins travailleurs les
prisons oui autres auprès de ce public
là je peux vous dire que on n'est pas
prêt il suffit d'une demi heure va pas
pour faire un attentat l'on prend plutôt
on va en bas de chez soi avec une
attaque des innocents c'est pas en
allant pointer au commissariat même tous
les jours pas sortir il faudrait voir
beaucoup plus strict de dessins et et là
on est en train en fait deux par
principe ou galati peur on est en train
de se créer un problème qui va être
insurmontable on a vu des vertes et pour
les policiers pour leur enseignement
puisque on n'a pas encore fini d'arrêter
les revenant du diable on n'a pas encore
trouvé de solution pour les djihadistes
qui étaient incarcérés dans le nord de
la syrie et on est déjà en train de se
créer un autre problème avec des
djihadistes qui sont pas du tout et
radicalisée et et pour qui on met des
mesures de suivi qui sont absolument pas
adapté au mode opératoire terroriste
actuelle près c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi prochain
point ce sera demain 7h du matin heure
française
[Musique]
comment
bâtie c'est de notre pas seulement le
cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]